Ah.
Wow.
Hört man mich?
Nee, dich hört man noch nicht.
Dein Spielzeug.
Hast du den falschen abgemacht. Du hast den falschen Kopfhörer weggelegt.
Ich habe dir dreimal gesagt.
Dass du die sechs. Ja, ja. Die sechs. Hier gibt es keine sechs. Vier, zwei, drei, eins.
Das sind Nummern. das sind Inventarnummern. Damit man das Korn nicht verhalten kann.
SKR 04, Alter.
SKR 04, forever.
Guck mal.
Jetzt sehen wir wieder nicht, was der Roland zeichnet.
Wir wollen das Bild hier sehen. Damit wir noch ordentlich abgelenkt sind.
Der Roland hat die Sendung für uns schon eröffnet.
Ja, ja, wir sind alle immer schon weiter als wir. Minus, weißt du was?
Wir müssen uns einen Sendungsanfang einteilen lassen.
Ich mach das mal, okay? Ich mach das ja sonst auch immer, ne?
Ja, mach mal.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, Nummer 256, hier sind wir endlich. Hallo,
schön, dass ihr alle gekommen seid. Ganz toll, im Babylon.
Grüß euch. Ganz willkommen.
Aber jetzt haben wir gar keinen guten Morgen, Linus, einen guten Morgen, Tim gemacht.
Ja, sorry.
Das ist immer, das Gemeine an diesem guten Morgen, Linus, guten Morgen,
Tim, ist, dass wir das wirklich immer spontan machen.
Und das ist manchmal anstrengend. Auf einer Bühne, so unter Druck,
kann ich manchmal nicht.
Ich hatte das jetzt schon wieder ganz vergessen.
Wie wir die Sendung beginnen. Ja, 255 so Dinger haben wir gemacht.
Du hast jetzt vergessen, wie das geht.
Ja gut, aber normalerweise läuft ja auch kein Jeopardy vorher.
Wie hat euch das Jeopardy gefallen.
Vielen Dank an Henning Letty, an Dennis, an Roland.
Und wer hat mitgespielt? Pupe, Barbarossa, Anna und Nujum.
Ich hatte ja gehofft, dass Anna mitmacht. Das habe ich ja auch gerade gesagt.
Ich habe gehofft, dass Anna mitmacht. Und ich habe gehofft, dass sie total verliert.
Aber leider nicht zu bremsen.
Soll ich dir was sagen? Die hat geübt.
Ja, bei Netzpolitik und .org hat sie geübt.
Da macht dir keiner was vor, Anna. Das war klar. Ja, und wir haben jetzt mal
wieder, also wir haben ja diese Veranstaltung, also wir haben eine ähnliche
Veranstaltung vor knapp einem anderthalb Jahr schon mal gemacht.
Da waren ja auch sehr viele von euch da.
Vielleicht könnt ihr euch mal melden, wer war denn letztes Mal schon so dabei?
Mal ein kurzes Handzeichen.
Das ist ein Drittel, ein Viertel vielleicht. Also viele neue Gäste, das ist schön.
Und wir sind ja immer sehr angetan von unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern und dem
ganzen Feedback, was so reinkommt und was glaube ich auch ganz erheblich dazu
beiträgt, dass uns das auch weiterhin so Spaß macht, muss man mal sagen.
Ja, ich finde das tatsächlich beeindruckend, dass sich so viele Leute für Politik interessieren.
Also wir machen ja einen Politik-Podcast, der sich dadurch auszeichnet,
eigentlich konsequent schlechte Laune zu machen und nur schlechte Nachrichten zu verbreiten.
Und ich bin tatsächlich immer wieder überrascht, dass wir euch dafür begeistern können.
Ich hoffe, im Rest eures Lebens sieht es einfach viel sonniger aus als in unserem
Podcast, mit dem wir euch nervten.
Andererseits freue ich mich enorm,
Ja, dass es Menschen gibt, die sich für diesen ja doch sehr wichtigen Politikbereich interessieren,
den voranbringen und dass wir dann sowas wie heute Abend machen können,
wo wir eine Mischung aus hoffentlich viel Spaß und guter Laune und eben auch
wichtigen ernsten Angelegenheiten,
die unsere Zukunft und unser Leben betreffen,
mit euch besprechen können.
Und ganz besonders freue ich mich auch tatsächlich, dass also bei den in die
Planung der Gäste und Gäste gibt es einen Weiblichen?
Das ist auch so ein Thema, ich kann es dir nicht beantworten.
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht.
Die Mitgestaltenden,
das ist natürlich immer, also wir haben da einen gewissen Anspruch an uns selber,
wir wollen ja nicht immer nur das Gleiche machen, müssen neue Leute her,
die noch nicht in der Sendung waren und vor allem vielleicht auch mal,
andere Themen oder zumindest eins, zwei andere Themen, so ein bisschen für euch
eine bunte Mischung herbeistellen.
Das ist immer relativ viel Arbeit und deswegen bin ich jetzt auch ganz aufgeregt,
weil ich nicht weiß, ob es uns gelingt, das hier sauber über die Bühne zu kriegen.
Ich meine, ich könnte stolpern, guck mal, wie viel Kabel du hier schon wieder hingelegt hast und so.
Dass ihr euch immer für Sorgen macht. Kinder.
Das läuft schon. So wie ich von Anfang an überzeugt war, dass das auch mit uns ganz gut funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir die Story schon das letzte Mal erzählt haben, aber...
Ich glaube, die erzählen wir jedes Mal. Das ist aber nicht schlimm,
weil das mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung erzählen wir ja auch jedes Mal.
Aber ich kann es ja vielleicht mal so aus meiner Perspektive erzählen,
weil ich ja nun diese Podcasterei schon eine Weile betreibe und mir immer so
Gedanken mache so, okay, was müsstest du denn eigentlich als nächstes tun?
Und jetzt bin ich ja eigentlich relativ faul, auch mit meinen Interview-Podcasts.
Ja, das stimmt auf jeden Fall. Du hast irgendwie Ahnung und so, erzähl doch mal.
Ich sag mal alle fünf Minuten kurz was. Und dann ist das mein Produkt.
Das ist natürlich ganz schön schlau von mir auch.
Und dann haben wir beim Camp 2011 gestanden, ich habe dich zugetextet und hast
dir gedacht, könnte klappen.
Nee, tatsächlich haben wir bei irgendeiner bierschwangeren anderen Veranstaltung
uns irgendwann mal auf dem Balkon getroffen und dann hast du mir gebeichtet,
dass du irgendwie meine Podcasts hörst, die du wohl auch ein bisschen leiden kannst.
Und, weiß nicht, da haben wir so ein bisschen aus den Augen verloren,
aber irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Und ich dachte mir halt so die ganze Zeit so, so Netzpolitik scheint irgendwie,
das ist irgendwie was, darüber muss mal gesprochen werden.
Das wird noch was. Das könnte sich durchsetzen.
Das kommt nochmal ganz groß raus. Es ist so ein Gefühl und das hat eben auch
viel, jetzt sind wir schon wieder am Anfang, das hat eben auch viel mit dieser
Interaktion mit den Leuten, die zuhören, zu tun.
Wenn mich Leute treffen, dann höre ich halt oft sowas wie, oh ja,
du kennst mich nicht, aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich kenne dich gut und so,
weil ja dieses asymmetrische Verhältnis im Podcast ja im Prinzip auch ganz normal ist.
Andererseits empfinde ich das selber gar nicht so, weil ich schon ein ganz gutes
Gefühl, glaube ich, also zwar jetzt nicht für das Individuum,
aber sozusagen für die Art von Menschen, die jetzt an so ein Informationsangebot auch andocken.
Ich merke halt immer wieder, dass das eigentlich alles sehr,
kluge Leute sind, die irgendwie einfach alle sehr erträglich auch sind und auch
so getragen sind von diesem, man muss doch die Dinge auch irgendwie besser hinkriegen.
Und dieses Feedback, das ist schon wichtig und das hat dann halt so bei mir
dazu geführt, dass ich mir so dachte, okay, das muss jetzt irgendwie moderiert werden.
Und dann war halt so die Idee, gut, der Linus und so, ich meine,
der Witz ist ja immer so, you've got the brain, I've got the looks.
Er hat natürlich jetzt beides, das ist ein bisschen blöd, aber trotzdem hatte
ich so das Gefühl, das könnte ganz gut funktionieren.
Und du hast dich da ja reingestürzt, ohne jetzt eigentlich auch wirklich zu
wissen, worauf du dich da einlässt.
Ja, aber das merke ich mir, wenn mich jemand fragt, was machst du,
dann sagst du ja so einen Podcast und wenn die dann sagen, ich kenne den nicht,
dann sag ich, ja, ja, nee, nee, der ist für Kluge.
Wir hören Kluge. Wir machen einen Podcast für Kluge. Das finde ich schön.
Das ist schön. Kluge und schöne Menschen.
Kluge und schön. Schön seid ihr. Zumindest von hier.
Also ausgesucht. Wo sind die eigentlich?
Wollen wir noch was zu dem Ort hier sagen? Ich kann da nichts zu sagen.
Ich weiß nur, das ist ein ganz cooles Kino.
Achso. Das hat mich aber nichts vorbereitet. Und sagt bestimmt vielleicht was
Falsches. Aber das Babylon gibt es schon sehr, sehr lange und war...
Oh, da gehen schon die ersten Facepalms. 1929.
1929. Siehst du mal, die Experten. Was war 1929?
Gerade was war 1929? Immer Fragen.
Aber wir müssen auf unseren Sondergast hinweisen. Der einzige Mensch, der hier rauchen darf.
Ach so, ja. Das ist Ernst Lubitsch. Der sitzt da immer. Er ist halt ein Vertreter
der deutschen Filmgeschichte. Eine Filmgeschichte, eine ganz einflussreiche.
Kennt nicht unbedingt jemand, aber wenn ihr die Gelegenheit nachher noch habt,
dann könnt ihr ihm auch noch Hallo sagen und googeln, so sein oder nicht sein.
Das sind so diese Filme, aber ich wollte jetzt hier keine Abhandlung über Filmgeschichte
halten, weil da bin ich auch kein Experte, da macht man immer einen Podcast.
Also lässt sich jemand ein.
Ich lasse andere reden, na klar, ist viel zu anstrengend. Nichtsdestotrotz,
es ist schon fast ein bisschen peinlich, aber ich habe irgendwie 20 Jahre gebraucht,
bis ich diesen Ort hier endlich mal betreten habe.
Ich war zwar schon mal da, aber nur in dem anderen Saal, als ich dann irgendwie
hier reinkam vor ein paar Monaten, fiel ich halt fast vom Stuhl,
weil das einfach ein wunderschöner Ort ist, sehr angemessen,
auch ähnlich dem Delphi, wo wir letztes Mal waren,
also mit Balkon und so, aber für unsere Zwecke wirklich wunderbar geeignet und
wir sind hier auch sehr nett empfangen worden und soweit läuft das alles total
super und deswegen dachten wir uns, ist das der richtige Ort.
So, wir wollen jetzt aber eigentlich gar nicht so viel unter uns reden,
sondern im Prinzip das Format, was wir letztes Mal schon gemacht haben,
aufgreifen und haben uns Gäste eingeladen.
Wollen wir jetzt erstmal alle vorstellen oder wollen wir einfach mal nacheinander anfangen?
Ich glaube, wir stellen, also wir haben es ja in der vorvorletzten Sendung schon
mal erwähnt und wenn ihr das nicht gehört habt, dann könnt ihr euch heute überraschen.
Genau.
Und unser, jetzt ist die Frage, jetzt kommt das wieder mit dem Gästin oder Gast.
Ich habe das neulich mal nachgeschlagen tatsächlich und es steht im,
weiß nicht, Duden, gibt es tatsächlich das Wort Gästin.
Gibt es, okay.
Ja, also es ist verzeichnet, aber mit dem Hinweis, dass es auch sehr,
ich weiß nicht genau, wie es da formuliert ist, aber dass es sozusagen nicht,
sehr gebräuchlich ist oder ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Formulierung da konkret
war. Und dem ist ja auch so.
Vernünftige Sprache ist ohnehin nicht sehr gebräuchlich. Das heißt,
wir können ja trotzdem anwenden. Also unsere erste Gästin.
Und jetzt hätte ich nämlich, jetzt mussten wir gleich helfen.
Jetzt geht es gleich weiter.
Genau, jetzt kommt unsere erste Gästin, oder? Sollen wir machen?
Ja, jetzt kommt unsere erste Gästin, genau.
Und du musst jetzt einen Knopf drücken, oder?
Das ist richtig.
Ich muss nicht nur einen Knopf drücken. Warte mal noch kurz.
Dennis hilft dir.
Ich muss auch noch ein Kabel reinstecken.
Kabel?
Was? Ob ich mein eigenes habe, mein eigenes was?
Nee, ich mach das so.
So ist das immer. Der Mann baut seit zwölf Jahren an diesem Studio rum.
Und jedes Mal, wenn man da reinkommt, sagt er, Linus, es ist fertig.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Ja, so ist es nicht.
Wenn man Sachen nicht mehr verbessern kann oder der Meinung ist,
da geht nichts mehr, dann muss man sofort sein lassen und was anderes tun.
Und von daher ist so Work in Progress eigentlich auch ganz cool.
Wie viel Work in Progress haben wir denn dann heute noch?
Das wird sich dann noch so zeigen. Guck jetzt mal, dass ich das hier korrekt hinbekomme.
Aber wir kommen jetzt zu unserer ersten Gästin. Das ist nämlich Géraldine de
Bastion, sagt man, und die bitten wir jetzt mal zu uns auf die Bühne. Hallo, Géraldine.
Ja,
das ist ganz gut. Wir werden ja noch drei weitere Gäste sein.
Kannst du das üben? Doch, ist mein Ernst.
Verdammte Axt.
Guck mal, da ist jetzt jemand auf die Bühne gekommen.
Hallo.
Entschuldigung, wir sind total verspult.
Hallo Geraldine, meine erste Frage an dich ist tatsächlich, spricht man dich
wirklich The Bastion aus?
Man kann es The Bastion oder The Bastion aussprechen. Hauptsache man sagt nicht
Geraldine, aber ansonsten ist Vor- und Nachname gerne entweder auf Deutsch oder Verzösen.
Dann bleibe ich nämlich gerne wieder lieber bei The Bastion.
So habe ich dich nämlich immer genannt.
Aber ich habe auf der Republika-Bühne und dann meinte Tim, dass er dich angerufen
hat und du mit The Bastion drangegangen. Der ist jetzt erstmal beschäftigt.
Das ist so ein bisschen situationsabhängig.
Okay, und dich haben wir eingeladen auf unserer Suche nach Leuten,
die eigentlich immer in unserem Dunstkreis so sich bewegt haben und bewegen.
Du hast ja zum Beispiel den CCC-Kongress eröffnet, den 32 oder 31 C3,
die Eröffnungsrede gehalten, zusammen mit Erdgeist.
Du machst seit über zehn Jahren bei der Republika mit und du ersetzt dich sehr viel mit...
Entwicklung, nee, internationale Zusammenarbeit auseinander.
Ja, genau. All diese Dinge.
Darüber wollen wir heute mit dir sprechen.
Ich freue mich sehr. Ich freue mich wirklich sehr, hier zu sein.
Und es ist sehr aufregend.
Hörst du eigentlich Podcast? Hörst du eigentlich Podcast?
Ja, ab und zu mal. Aber nicht ganz so regelmäßig, muss ich sagen.
Immer mal eher sporadisch. Manchmal den von Ulf, manchmal den von euch.
Gibt dir das was?
Ja. Also erstmal Information, natürlich. Dann hört man die Stimmen netter Menschen,
die man nicht immer sieht.
Und gerade wenn man weiß, dass es A, sehr qualifizierte Menschen sind,
von denen man Informationen aufnimmt und dann auch noch Menschen,
die man gerne hat, finde ich, das ist eine sehr schöne Mischung.
Das ging ja runter wie Öl.
So, und unser Podcast, also jetzt hast du ja über Ulf's Podcast gesprochen.
Da steht übrigens eine Flasche Wasser für dich. Der Tim ist nur nicht so,
der ist viel zu sehr mit seiner Technik befestigt. Referentenwasser ist immer schon geöffnet, Tim.
Ach so, echt?
Referentenwasser, schau mal auf. und keine Kohlensäuber.
Das habe ich gelernt, als einmal jemand beim Kongress eine Palette Referentenwasser
holen sollte und mit Blubber Wasser ankam und der Anschiss, der dann folgte,
hat für alle Raum gereicht, das zu lernen, das Referentenwasser immer...
Ohne.
Es ist ein weniger Verschluckungsgefahr bei der ganzen Aufregung.
Ja, und die Rülpserei ist ja auch nicht zu ertragen.
Tim, hast du deine Technik da jetzt geklärt? Wir wollten gerade ganz kurz noch eine Sendung machen.
Ja, ich glaube.
So, Geraldine, also, pass auf. Republika. Das interessiert jetzt. Warum?
Die Republika, also ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass wir jetzt beide so ein bisschen
in diesem Chaos irgendwie drinstecken.
So der CCC, wir fühlen uns jetzt hier nicht als Sprachrohr des CCC,
das mag vielleicht manchmal so wahrgenommen werden, aber dem ist nicht so.
Wir sind da halt ein Teil davon und reflektieren in gewisser Hinsicht diese
ganze Kultur und nehmen halt so ein Stück weit eben auch an diesem ganzen Eventgeschehen teil.
Der Kongress ist so das große Ding beim Club und ist ja irgendwie enorm gewachsen, völlig absurd.
15.000 Leute kommen da hin und was glaube ich wenigen klar ist,
ist, das ist halt nicht nur die größte Hacker-Konferenz, sondern das ist die größte Konferenz.
Und vermutlich, also auf jeden Fall in Europa und wenn nicht sogar auch darüber hinaus.
Es gibt natürlich Messen und so, wo so theoretisch mehr Leute kommen,
aber so, wo wirklich Konferenzprogramm ist, Vortragsprogramm,
Inhalt etc., das über viele Tage läuft.
Dann kam irgendwann die Republika. Und die Republika finde ich insofern sehr
interessant, als dass sie sich ja in gewisser Hinsicht aus so einem ähnlichen
Schleim zusammengesetzt hat.
Es gab da so Verschiebungen, aber auch extrem viel Überschneidung,
personelle Überschneidung.
Auch ich war von Anfang an dabei, fand das auch immer gut. Hat jetzt nicht so
allen Hackern von vornherein so zugesagt oder so, aber war auch irgendwie Digitalien etc.
Und jetzt ist das Ding auch so gewachsen und wo seid ihr da jetzt angekommen? 10.000?
Ja, es gibt noch nicht die finaloffiziellen Zahlen von diesem Jahr,
aber es waren wohl über 10.000.
So.
Also aus mehr oder weniger demselben Kulturraum oder zumindest einem Kulturraum,
der sich sehr nahe steht, erwachsen auf einmal so zwei Formate,
die versuchen irgendwie in diese Gesellschaft zurückzustrahlen.
Jetzt ist ja Netzpolitik so quasi vertreten durch Markus Beckner,
natürlich vor allem Netzpolitik.org und halt so die Popkultur,
würde ich mal jetzt sagen, so vertreten vor allem durch Johnny und Tanja.
Das sind ja so im Prinzip die beiden Säulen dieser Veranstaltung. Wie hast du denn das?
Und als drittes würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, eben auch Open Source und unsere
so offene Kultur, technisch gesehen, wie auch gesellschaftlich durch New Thinking
als dritten Akteur. Ja, Andreas.
Wie nimmst du das wahr? Also welche Bedeutung hat Netzpolitik in dieser Veranstaltung,
gehabt oder hat es noch? Also welche Rolle spielt es da?
Als Thema? Nicht als Organisation?
Nee, als Thema.
Also ich glaube, das ist einer der Kerngründe, warum zumindest von Markus'
Seite her, aber auch von vielen von den anderen Menschen, die da mitwirken oder
auch in den Gründerkreisen, warum es diese Veranstaltung gibt,
ist, dass man dezidierende Veranstaltung haben wollte, die sich gesellschaftspolitisch
mit Netzthemen beschäftigt.
Und vielleicht ein bisschen weniger technisch an die ganzen Themen rangeht,
als es beim CCC der Fall ist. und
da einfach auch nochmal eine andere gesellschaftliche Breite herstellt.
Ich glaube, es gibt natürlich, wie du gesagt hast, ganz viele gewollte Überlappungen
und es ist ja auch ganz wichtig, dass wir diesen Kulturkreis teilen und uns
da gegenseitig auch anschauen und inspirieren.
Aber es ist eben auch Anspruch der Republika, dass Menschen,
die ganz wenig technisches Verständnis haben, hinkommen und netzpolitische Themen
so verpackt bekommen, dass sie ihnen wichtig vorkommen, dass sie sie annehmen
können und in ihrem Arbeitsleben weiterverarbeiten können.
Ob das ein Lehrer oder ein Agenturmensch ist.
Und jetzt ging das irgendwann mal los, also die Republika auf jeden Fall,
sie drängt in die Mitte der Gesellschaft, ne?
Das ist das Ziel, ja.
Mit Daimler als Sponsor.
Mit Daimler als Sponsor, mit kommerziellen Sponsoren, ich glaube,
das ist einer der großen Unterschiede zu dem CCC.
Die Republika ist eine kommerzielle Veranstaltung, die Republika hat Sponsoren
und ich finde Daimler ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel, weil sie ja lange auch eine
der Hauptsponsoren der Republika gewesen sind. Und wie viele unserer Sponsoren
kann man das per se sehr kritisch sehen.
Genauso wie man kritisch sehen kann, dass Microsoft ein Sponsor von der Republika ist.
Aber genau solche Begegnungen sind gewollt. Als der Zerske damals gesagt hat,
ja, ich möchte vielleicht auch gerne einen Vortrag halten.
Das ist keine gute Idee, aber was du machen kannst, kannst dich mit Blogger auf die Bühne setzen.
Irgendeinen jungen Mobility-Blogger, der eine ganz andere Perspektive auf deine
Themen hat und dich mit dem unterhalten.
Und es war dann auch eine coole Session. Und so versuchen wir natürlich auch
mit den Akteuren, die wir einladen, die vielleicht eben nicht aus unserem Kreis kommen, umzugehen.
Dass sie da irgendwie zurechtkommen. Jetzt hat die Republika mal angefangen.
Ich weiß nicht, wann hat es aufgehört, dass die Republika Blogger-Treffen genannt wird?
Schon eine ganze Weile.
Als sie anfingen, sie Blogger-Messe zu nennen.
Aber lag das daran, dass die Republika sich wirklich auch einfach breiter und
größer positioniert hat?
Oder lag das daran, dass einfach alle keine Blogs mehr hatten, sondern Instagram?
Es ist eine Mischung aus beiden. Einmal wirklich die Themenbreite und wer soll
sich damit identifizieren, dass man da eben als Sprecher oder als Teilnehmer
einfach sich als Kern des Ganzen fühlt,
aber natürlich auch, weil sich unsere digitale Medienlandschaft einfach verändert
hat und bloggen 2007 was anderes ist als bloggen heute,
diese ganze Social-Media-Welle, wo irgendwie dann ist dann jeder,
der irgendwie ein Instagram-Account hat und auf Twitter mehr als 500 Follower
auch bloggt und dann hat sich das natürlich so ein bisschen aufgeweicht einfach,
wer eben im Kern dieser Veranstaltung ist.
Und dein Teil, du wirst ja genannt der Republika-Kuratorin.
Ja, ich bin seit, also 2012 hat Markus entschieden, dass es vielleicht mal eine
gute Idee wäre, nicht mehr alleine das Programm zu machen, sondern mit anderen zu teilen.
Da habe ich das übernommen und bin seitdem Teil des Programmteams,
wobei ich schon seit ein paar Jahren nicht mehr die Programmleitung mache.
Sondern deshalb Sandra Mametschlange gemacht und jetzt die Alexandra Wolf.
Und wie siehst du da so Kuratoren,
sagt man so eine Handschrift nach, oder wie hast du da deine,
wie hast du das Republika-Programm irgendwie gesehen, das ist ja,
also ich meine die Republika hat viel, viel, viel mehr Programme als der Kongress,
dieses Jahr waren das, wie viele Stages gleichzeitig? 14 oder was?
Verrückt, viele Bühnen, die laufen und dann
haben wir auch angefangen mit unterschiedlichen Formaten, das neben den,
Stages, sieben Stages plus die zwei Media Convention Stages,
dass die halt alle auch gefilmt werden, wo alle Inhalte ins Netz gestellt werden,
eben diese Meetups haben, dass wir Programme an den Ständen zum Teil haben.
Also es ist wirklich eine Flut von Content einfach, die da kommt.
Und ich glaube, wir alle im Programmteam versuchen, unsere persönlichen Interessen,
unser Blick auf unsere ganze digitale Welt mit einzubringen und dementsprechend
das Programm mitzugestalten, auch wenn natürlich ganz wichtig ist,
dass der Kern des Republika-Programms, der kommt von allen Leuten,
die im Call for Participation was einreichen,
und selber dieses Programm mitgestalten.
Also eigentlich besetzen wir ja nur die Hauptbühne und gewisse andere Panels,
aber was wir halt auch machen, ist einfach super viel Arbeitszeit in diese Call
for Paper zu stecken, dass wir sehen,
wenn zwei Leute was Spannendes zum selben Thema eingereicht haben,
dass wir die manchmal versuchen miteinander zu vernetzen oder zu sagen,
hey, guck mal, da macht was, gerade wenn es auch so ein bisschen obskure Sachen
sind, die wir aber cool finden, dass sich daraus dann auch eben Communities
bilden sollen und wir die Leute miteinander in Verbindung bringen.
Und für mich ist es natürlich so, dass, wie du schon gesagt hast,
ich arbeite auch in der internationalen Zusammenarbeit viel.
2012 ist es mir persönlich extrem aufgefallen, als ich damals die Programmleitung
gemacht habe, dass wir immer noch vorwiegend Sprecher und Sprecherinnen aus
den USA und aus Europa haben und mit diesen ganzen globalen Themen,
die uns beschäftigen, aber immer noch wirklich eine sehr beschränkte Sichtweise
haben und vor allem eine beschränkte Sichtweise an unser Publikum geben von
den Leuten, die wir einladen.
Und deswegen war es einfach schon immer mein Anliegen, das so ein bisschen aufzubrechen.
2013 hat dann Eric Herschman die Eröffnungskino gegeben.
Das ist ein kenianischer Unternehmer, der zum Beispiel Ushahidi mitgegründet
hat, das iHub und Brick, also verschiedenste Sachen.
Da musst du kurz ein paar von erklären.
Gerne.
Darf ich da mal kurz reingrutschen? Wenn wir jetzt die Republika gerade dabei
sind zu verlassen, eine Frage hätte ich schon noch gerne.
Der Ansatz der Republika quasi in die Gesellschaft zu strahlen,
denkst du, dass der funktioniert?
Ja, ich denke ja und ich glaube, das hat man spätestens dieses Jahr durch das
Auftreten der Bundeswehr gesehen.
Ich bin immer noch schockiert darüber, und so geht es auch ganz vielen Leuten
bei uns im Team, dass sozusagen der Anspruch da ist, von Regierungsseite,
zumindest vom Verteidigungsministerium, Bundeswehrseite zu sagen,
wir erheben den Anspruch, Teil dieser Konferenz zu sein, da vertreten zu sein.
Und wenn wir nicht eingeladen werden, dann fühlen wir das als eine Beschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit.
Das ist natürlich eine ganz furchtbar, sehr anmutende, rechtspopulistische Haltung aus den USA.
Aber alleine, dass das passiert ist und der ganze Umgang damit seitens Staatssekretär etc.
Petra, finde ich, zeigt wirklich, dass da dieses Ziel auf ganz,
ganz traurige, ganz verrückte und auch wirklich politisch sehr,
sehr bedenkliche Art und Weise irgendwie auf jeden Fall erfüllt wurde,
weil wie kann es sonst sein, dass auf eine private Veranstaltung,
so ein Zugriff erfolgt.
Ja, das war schon eine merkwürdige Sache. Wir wollten das nicht unbedingt Wir
hatten es jetzt gar nicht vor, das jetzt unbedingt anzusprechen,
aber du hast natürlich recht.
Auf einmal, man hat so das Gefühl, wenn man irgendwie dann nicht auf der Republika
gehört wird, dann wird man in der Tagesschau totgeschwiegen oder so.
Das ist schon echt absurd.
Und ich meine, auch der CC und die Republika haben ja beide eine große mediale
Coverage. Und natürlich sieht man das auch in anderen Bereichen,
man sieht es daran, dass...
Auch innerhalb der Veranstaltungen, wie dieses Jahr, gab es einen super schönen
großen Kids-Base und Menschen fühlen sich mit ihren Familien willkommen.
Es sind wirklich so unterschiedliche Arten von Menschen mittlerweile da,
die sich aber hoffentlich alle irgendwie willkommen fühlen und entweder so ein
bisschen dieses doch immer noch so reinschnuppern, das, was den Kern irgendwie
ausmacht und Teil unserer Community ist,
oder auch das Ganze neu interpretieren so ein bisschen.
Natürlich ist es auch manchmal für uns schwierig, da so die Balance zu halten.
Letztes Jahr gab es halt total den Run von verschiedenen Ministerien,
weil Wahlkampfjahr und alle wollen einen Platz auf der Bühne und du willst natürlich
Menschen einladen und auch Politik oder eben Wirtschaft einladen,
um wirklich Themen zu diskutieren und auch diese Auseinandersetzung zu bestimmten
Themen zu haben und auch das zeigt glaube ich,
dass man auf jeden Fall eine Relevanz gesellschaftlicher hat.
Ja, denn dein zweites Steckenpferde, das hast du wahrscheinlich noch ein paar
mehr Steckenpferde Also bevor ich das wieder vergesse hier das ist mein T-Shirt,
Ja, du bist ja ja auch bist du betroffen Ich bin persönlich nicht betroffen.
Da ich meinen zweiten Pass behalten darf, das wird sich nicht ändern durch Brexit,
wie man dann im Praktischen betroffen ist Meine Schwester wohnt in London arbeitet
da, also ich glaube sie ist zum Beispiel viel mehr Betroffener.
Sie ist Musikerin, kommt auf Tour nach Europa und dann wird sich bestimmt vieles
zum Negativen verändern.
Persönlich emotional betroffen bin ich natürlich sehr davon,
wie von vielen politischen Entwicklungen in diesem Land.
Kann ich gut nachvollziehen. Aber du bist...
Also ich weiß, du hast ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie viel Zeit hast du in Italien gelebt?
Ich bin da geboren, aber bin als kleines Baby schon wieder nach Berlin gezogen
und habe dann tatsächlich eine weirte Highschoolzeit in einem kleinen Ort in
the middle of nowhere verbracht, der Yvesham heißt.
Genau, bin 90 weggezogen und 96 zurückgezogen.
Also du bist, du hast ja so ein bisschen so eine, ich finde das so eine Gnade,
wenn man sozusagen von vornherein mit mehr als einer Sprache,
mehr als einer Kultur aufwächst, weil ich denke, das macht gleich den Kopf auf,
da gibt es noch was anderes da draußen, das ist nicht alles so wie das,
was ich vor allem kennengelernt habe.
Auch für mich als absolutes Stadtkind und Berlinerin auf so einen 14.000-Einwohner-Ort
zu ziehen und da irgendwie wirklich mit 13, was schon eine besondere Erfahrung
war, wo man denkt so, jetzt geht's los, ich kann Berlin nochmal anders kennenlernen.
Dann sitzt man da auf einmal auf so einem englischen Caf und muss sein ganzes Leben neu umholen.
Aber es war für mich eine super wertvolle Erfahrung, als ich nach Berlin zurückgezogen
bin. habe ich mir damals schon gedacht, ich habe wirklich andere Seiten nochmal
gesehen, die die Menschen, mit denen ich hier zur Schule gegangen bin,
auf eine relativ gut behütete Schule, bei der John Kelly die Schule, nie gesehen haben.
Und so wirklich dieses Dorfelend zum Beispiel oder auch einfach wie Menschen
in so einer Stadt wirklich ganz andere Perspektiven mit sich bringen,
aber natürlich auch so die Nähe und andere soziale Gefüge, die auch super schön
sein können, die man hier anders erfährt.
Was ist Dorfelend? Kein DSL?
Der kommt zweimal am Tag und bis. Das ist das höchste der Gefühle,
dass wir irgendwann mal nach, wir sind immer in Cheltenham ausgegangen und einkaufen
gegangen, was später eine ganz andere Relevanz und Bedeutung bekommen hat,
das wusste ich damals nicht. Und...
Und du bist einfach in einer ganz kleineren Blase und musst dir dann die große
Welt irgendwie anders erschließen gedanklich, weil es einfach nicht so automatisch
passiert, wie wenn man in einer Stadt wie Berlin lebt.
Also Cheltenham, da wo der Geheimdienst sitzt. Ich bin da mal in diesem großen
Gebäude vorbeigefahren.
Das sieht richtig nach Geheimdienst aus.
Aber worauf ich hinaus wollte ist das hat dich so ein bisschen zu einer internationalen
Person gemacht, ich meine du moderierst,
aber du tourst ja jetzt auch viel durch die Gegend, hast jetzt glaube ich für
Arten Film gemacht, der ist aber noch gar nicht erschienen, der kommt erst im August oder wie war das?
Ja, der wird im August ausgestrahlt auf Arte, aber ich weiß noch nicht,
ob es der Produktionsfirma aufgefallen ist aber mir ist auf jeden Fall letztens
aufgefallen, dass wir den Film auf der Republika prämiert haben Und wie ich.
Bereits erwähnte, filmen wir ja alle Bühnen ab.
Das heißt, wenn man sich klug anstellt, kann man ihn tatsächlich auch bereits
jetzt auf YouTube gucken.
Okay, ich bin jetzt irgendwie davon ausgegangen, dass das nicht stattgefunden
hat. Okay, umso besser. Aber was hast du da gemacht und warum?
Ja, ich hatte nie so einen, boah, du musst unbedingt nach Afrika drangen,
den ja manche Menschen irgendwie haben. Das hat sich bei mir alles mehr oder
weniger durch Zufall ergeben.
Und zwar habe ich tatsächlich früher für die deutsche Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
gearbeitet, aber ich wollte dann nach Berlin zurückkommen, bin irgendwann einfach
bei Markus und Andreas bei New Thinking aufgeschlagen und meinte,
hey, ich kenne euch von Wieses und von anderen Veranstaltungen.
Lass uns einfach was zusammen machen und gib mir eine E-Mail-Adresse am Schreibtisch
und ich finde irgendwie ein cooles Projekt.
Und drei, vier Monate später hatten wir ein Vierjahresprojekt,
wo es um die Entwicklung von Open Source Business Modellen in verschiedenen
afrikanischen Ländern ging und so fing einfach diese ganze Afrika-Reise für
mich an, also eigentlich über diese Open-Source-Schiene und,
Und damals bin ich dann einfach in verschiedene Länder gereist,
was ich auch seitdem mache und hatte immer schon den Anspruch,
dass man sich irgendwie raus aus den offiziellen Meetingräumen und irgendwelchen
fensterlosen Konferenzhotelzimmern bewegt und einfach mal guckt,
was machen da Leute eigentlich und sowas ähnliches gesucht haben wie Hackerspaces,
weil es halt so eine eigene Kultur entsprochen hat und dachte,
irgendwie muss es doch hier sowas auch geben.
Heimat.
Genau. Und am Anfang war sowas wirklich schwierig zu finden,
aber irgendwann fing es dann an, dass sowas immer mehr aufgekommen ist.
Nicht unbedingt Hackerspaces in so einem Kern, wie wir es hier haben,
aber schon einfach Community Spaces, Coworking Spaces, verschiedene Orte,
wo sich einfach junge Menschen, die Internet gesucht haben, versammelt haben, um Ideen zu entwickeln.
Und habe dann da einfach angefangen, Zeit zu verbringen.
Aber es sind ja nicht nur diese Hacker-Spaces, die jetzt irgendwie irgendwas
kopieren, was wir auch haben, sondern Afrika nimmt ja auch, ich glaube,
das haben noch gar nicht so viele Leute begriffen, also wir hatten ja hier diese
schöne Witzkategorie mit Entwicklungsformen, ja,
tatsächlich ist uns ja Afrika in mancherlei Hinsicht auch weit voraus.
Also es hat sich, ich weiß nicht, wer das weiß, aber früher war es ja irgendwie
schwierig, irgendeine Infrastruktur aufzubauen, wenn man ein Telefonkabel verlegt
hat, waren die halt zwei Stunden später schon wieder verbuddelt und auf dem
Kupfermarkt verhökert.
Durch den Mobilfunk hat sich das alles komplett geändert.
Es hat immer eine Fühlung wieder. Wie ganz viele Sachen muss man sowas natürlich
immer so ein bisschen ausgewogen betrachten.
Ja, in vielerlei Hinsicht schon. Mobile Zahlungssysteme sind schon seit Jahren
in Kenia viel, viel verbreiteter und absoluter Standard, wo man hier immer noch
sich wirklich mühsam damit tut.
Und einer meiner liebsten Momente während dieses Filmdrehs, da habe ich zufällig
jemanden getroffen, der auch gerade eine Art Doku fertig gedreht hatte und zwar
über Whitespaces in Gegenden, wo man keinen Empfang hat.
Und dann wirklich dieses klassische, ja man muss nur einmal nach Berlin rausfahren,
20 Minuten Brandenburg ist das Netz weg und da muss der ja auf den Mount Kenia
klettern, wo auch wirklich keine Menschen mehr leben, um keinen Empfang zu haben.
In der Hinsicht ist man auf jeden Fall voraus, allerdings, und das hat eine
Freundin und Kollegin, Najira Samboudi, gesagt, muss man halt auch sehen,
wie viele, ich würde mal auch hier ins Publikum fragen, wie viele Leute coden
wirklich auf dem Handy, wie viele Leute schreiben akademische Texte auf dem
Handy, Wie viele Leute schaffen wirklich komplexen Content auf dem Handy.
Und wenn alles immer mobile first, mobile first und so diese Leapfrogging-Narrative
so präsent ist und das so hochgehebelt wird,
was heißt das aber eigentlich langfristig für den Kontinent,
der sich ja gerade auch als Schöpfer von Technik und nicht nur als Empfänger
von Sachen, die wir hier entwickeln, sehen will.
Und du würdest sagen, das hat ein negative, also wie sieht es denn aus in Afrika
gerade? Also ich war längere Zeit nicht da.
Afrika ist ja auch ein relativ großer Kontinent.
Du hast jetzt viel von Kenia gesprochen.
Ja, also meine Reise für den Film ging durch Kenia, Rwanda und Ghana,
die alle super unterschiedlich sind von der politischen Struktur und auch von
der Internetlandschaft her.
Ghana wahrscheinlich so das freiste Land von allen, was Medienfreiheit angeht
und einfach Demokratie an sich.
Aber dafür auch das Land mit der geringsten Internetpenetration.
Rwanda sicherlich das autoritärste Land,
aber wo die Regierung schon seit Jahren so ein bisschen das Estland Afrikas
sein möchte und einfach sich selber super vermarktet als der neue IT-Hub auf
dem Kontinent und es mittlerweile auch funktioniert, sodass mittlerweile auch wirklich Leute,
also dass da auch eine Community ist, die diese Regierungsrhetorik irgendwie
wirklich unterfüttert.
Ich glaube, da haben mittlerweile ungefähr 33 Prozent der Menschen Internetanschluss,
aber 70, 80 Prozent dann über Mobiltelefonzugang.
Ganz oft ist immer noch ein Problem, dass es so Datengefälle gibt,
also dass Leute vielleicht ein Handy haben, aber sich einfach kein Data leisten können.
Und Kenia hat einfach so eine der lebendigsten Tag-Szenen in Ostafrika,
wo einfach ganz viel passiert ist.
Ein bisschen das Feeling wie in Berlin auch, du kannst jeden Abend auf zig Events
gehen, es gibt ganz viele Spaces,
die auch unterschiedliche Funktionen erfüllen, manche wirklich mehr so einen
Hackerspace-Charakter und Künstler auch mitarbeiten und das einfach so ein bisschen
freigeistig ist, manche super businessmäßig, also irgendwie eine höhere Entwicklung
des Ökosystems, könnte man sagen.
Und in welche Richtung geht die Kultur? Also wird da quasi der gleiche Kram
gemacht und erfunden und gelebt wie hier?
Oder haben die vielleicht ein ganz anderes Verhältnis dazu, dadurch,
dass es nie eine PC-Welle gab, oder?
Ganz viele Menschen kennen ein Netz nur durch das Handy und Anwendung nur durchs
Handy. Es gibt natürlich Phänomene wie Zero-Rating.
Von Facebook ist ein Riesenphänomen.
Für ganz, ganz viele Menschen ist das das Internet und du hast zum Teil Handys,
die du kaufen kannst, wo schon ein Facebook-Knopf drauf ist oder du hast halt das Phänomen, dass du,
eben, weil du dir keine Daten leisten kannst, ein bisschen gefangen in diesem
Kreislauf bist und dann dreimal draufklicken musst, wenn du irgendwie auf einen
Link klickst, der raus aus dem Portal führt.
Twitter auch ganz oft geseruertet, also es ist wirklich auch nicht nur ein Facebook-Phänomen
und du dann dreimal zusagen musst, ja, ich möchte jetzt auf diese Anregung sagen,
ja, ich bin bereit, Daten dafür auszugeben, was natürlich auch Hürden einfach einbaut.
Sind sie bereit, jetzt in das Internet zu gehen?
Genau und das ist schon natürlich eine andere Kultur mit sich bringt als hier,
aber Menschen haben Bock drauf.
Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen der Unterschied kulturell, gesamtgesellschaftlich
zu Deutschland, dass du hier, als ich auf dieser Reise war, mir auf Twitter
irgendjemand so wie dieses Graph in Berlin, wo jemand gesprüht hat,
Digitalisierung ist scheiße und mach es weg.
Das würde ich jetzt überhaupt nie sehen, weil Leute in der Bevölkerung,
aber auch in vielen Regierungen, es einfach als unheimliche Chance sehen.
Und du dann Sätze von IT-Ministern hörst, die sagen,
ja, wir müssen dann Infrastruktur und freie, zugängliche, öffentliches Wiener
anders finanzieren und irgendwie durch andere Mehrwertsteuer und andere Wege einfach umsetzen.
Und das würde man hier natürlich auch super gerne mal von Leuten hören.
Wie blicken die denn auf Zero-Rating? Also unsere Position ist irgendwie relativ klar,
aber natürlich in diesen Ländern, in denen es noch keine so weit verbreiteten
Datenzugänge gibt und das ein Problem ist für Menschen, die wenig Geld haben,
die es dann auch nicht leisten können, dass sie dann wenigstens ein bisschen Internet kriegen?
Es gibt total unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu. Es gibt natürlich Leute,
die sich sehr politisch mit dem Thema beschäftigen, die genauso Netzneutralitätsverfechter
sind und gegen Zero-Ratings sind und meinen, dass wir eine Lobby aufbauen müssen,
um Telcos einfach dazu zu bringen, öffentliche WLANs zu kreieren und einfach
so ein bisschen, aber dafür ein freies Internet.
Es gibt viele Unternehmen, zum Beispiel die Brick-Leute, von denen ich erzählt
habe, das sind Leute, die sind guter, die ja auch...
Ohne schwierigen Bedingungen, einfach Staub, wenig Strom etc.
Funktioniert und die machen jetzt auch so ein öffentliches WLAN-Projekt an Bussen,
an Kiosks und für solche Leute ist es ein Thema,
für andere Menschen ist es auf jeden Fall eine Bereicherung und die sehen das
auch so, ein bisschen überrascht hat mich das auch,
es gibt jemanden, der in Ghana halt so eine totale Open-Source-Guru ist und
ganz viele Apps, die auch gerade so im Gesundheits- und Bildungsbereich echt cool sind,
der meinte, Nasty Rating ist ganz, ganz wichtig, um Leute erstmal so da ranzuführen,
ganz viele Leute, die, wie du gerade schon gesagt hast, eben kein Geld haben
und sehen es halt wirklich anders.
Und hat das eine Auswirkung auf die Menschen, die sich zwar Daten leisten können,
aber sagen, okay, ich möchte auch mit anderen Leuten kommunizieren,
die nicht so viel Geld haben wie ich, also nämlich nutze ich die Zero-gerateten Angebote?
Ja, und es gibt aber schon, es gab auch schon, bevor die ganzen Plattformen
so groß sind, von den Telcos-Geschichten, dass du so eine Call-me-back-SMS umsonst schicken konntest.
Und einfach so andere Herangehensweisen, an wie Kommunikation dann irgendwie
einfacher gemacht werden soll.
Und alles prepaid, ne?
Ja, es gibt überhaupt, also nicht mal in Ländern wie Südafrika,
wo es total Sinn machen würde, dass es einfach viel mehr Vertragsfonds gibt. Mittlerweile schon.
Jetzt langsam hat das angefangen, dass du dir auch, also nicht nur Südafrika,
auch in anderen Ländern Verträge holen kannst. Es hat ewig, ewig gedauert und
es ist immer noch fast alles über prepaid.
Und in dem Film, den ich gemacht habe, da geht es vor allem um verschiedene
Startups und Gründerszene.
Einfach versucht, so mal ein
bisschen zu gucken, wie ist da die unterschiedliche Mentalität von Leuten.
Und natürlich gibt es da auch E-Commerce-Anwendungen und Sachen,
die einfach kommerzig sind.
Aber es war schon, finde ich, echt schön zu sehen, dass die meisten von den
Leuten, die man mit mir gesprochen hat,
eine super soziale Mentalität haben, überhaupt nicht an irgendwelchen Exits
interessiert sind und keine Unternehmen aufziehen, weil sie einfach die Kiste
für viel Kohle verkaufen wollen, sondern weil sie was verändern wollen und irgendwie
ein ganz klares Problem vor Augen haben, was sie damit lösen wollen.
Gerade auch super viel im Hardware-Bereich, viele, viele Makerspaces,
die entstanden sind in den letzten Jahren,
die ganz viel in Gesundheitsanwendungen, Open-Source-Mikroskope, die adaptiert werden,
die vom MIT designt wurden, aber auch Sachen, die wirklich da designt werden,
welche digitalen Photoskope und ganz viele Bildungsanwendungen und einfach wirklich
viele coole, unterschiedliche Sachen, die da entwickelt werden.
Das können wir auch machen. Merkst du was? Wir hätten Gerardin mal lieber eine
richtige Sendung einladen können, wenn wir noch Stunden lang reden.
Ich komme gerne wieder.
Wir haben ja jetzt bisher nur eine halbe Stunde überzogen.
Also wir empfehlen auf jeden Fall erstmal deinen Film und dann würde mich noch interessieren,
Was glaubst du denn, also ist denn das der Begriff, dieses Begriffspaar voraus
irgendwie schon sehr fortgeschritten oder sowas, ist das da überhaupt zutreffend oder würde man,
entwickelt sich das da wirklich anders und wenn ja, wo ist das dann in zehn Jahren?
Puh, das ist fast unmöglich zu antworten auf den ganzen Kontinent bezogen.
Wie du schon gesagt hast, in 54 Ländern.
Riesenunterschiede in Kulturen, in Sprachräumen, in technischen Voraussetzungen.
Deswegen kann man das eigentlich nur auf bestimmte Szenen beantworten.
Ich glaube, man muss es halt, wie gesagt, nuanziert sehen.
Es ist ganz oft so, dass unterschiedlichste Lebensrealitäten gleichzeitig gelten.
Es gibt ganz viele Leute, die gar keinen Zugang haben, die nicht lesen und schreiben können.
Es gibt viele Leute, die benutzen Feature-Phones und keine Smartphones.
Es gibt aber viele Leute, die arbeiten in noch viel Hightech-Environments als
in vielen Bundesländern in Deutschland.
Und es existiert halt alles parallel.
Und das heißt, wenn du für diesen Markt entwickelst, dann ist es halt auch wichtig,
dass du diese unterschiedlichen Lebensrealitäten und Technikzugänge im Blick
hast und vielleicht einfach inklusiver an deine Technikprodukte rangehst.
Ich glaube, das ist einer der Unterschiede dazu.
Und glaubst du, dass wird Afrika oder das werden diese Länder selber besser können?
Weil also alles, was Zero-Rating ist, ist ja im Prinzip die Idee der existierenden Giganten des Westens,
zu sagen, alles klar, wenn da sich irgendwann mal Afrika und Teile Asiens irgendwie
dick digitalisieren, dann wollen wir bitteschön schon einen Knopf an deren Handys
haben, um sicherzugehen.
Ja, klar, das ist wie früher die Telekom-Magenta-Klassenzimmer bei uns.
Natürlich, oder früher, bevor diese ganze Bewegung so losging,
als ich angefangen habe, hinzureißen, wie oft habe ich in diesem Open-Source-Projekt
den Satz, ja, aber Microsoft ist all free in Afrika gehört, weil das einfach
die Wahrnehmung war, weil einfach Menschen rumgegangen sind und kostenlos.
Ja, kostenlos einfach ihre Software verteilt haben. Und es sind alles Log-In-Effekte,
die natürlich dadurch geschaffen werden sollen.
Und es gibt immer noch große Lücken und ganz, also gerade auch was so Schaffung
von Local Content und unterschiedlichen Sprachen angeht.
Natürlich gibt es super viele Baustellen, aber es gibt schon,
wie gesagt, auch wirklich dynamische, coole Entwicklerszenen und viele junge
Leute, die einfach Bock haben, was zu machen.
Und vielleicht noch zwei Sätze, was sich auf jeden Fall verändert hat, ist, dass es jetzt,
Und das Ziel von jungen Menschen ist, nicht bei einer großen Entwicklungsorganisation
zu arbeiten oder nicht bei einer großen internationalen Firma zu arbeiten,
sondern ihr Ding aufzubauen und ihr Startup oder ihre NGO oder ihr Entwicklungsprojekt,
Technikentwicklungsprojekt zu machen und damit die Gesellschaft zu verändern.
Und dass es mittlerweile auch anerkannt ist, dass Menschen sich nicht mehr irgendwie
verstecken müssen vor ihren Eltern, weil sie nicht Arzt werden wollen,
sondern Digitalunternehmer werden wollen.
Und ganz viele von den Unternehmern, die ich getroffen habe,
haben auch super kritischen Blick auf Entwicklungszusammenarbeit und auf die
ganze NGO-Szene, weil sie halt so projektbezogen,
kurzfristig denkend und in ihren Strukturen gefangen arbeitet und sehen oder
ist die Hoffnung von vielen Menschen,
dass dieses so, ich finde den Begriff auch ein bisschen schwierig,
aber dieses soziale Unternehmertum, das langsam anfängt mit zu ersetzen.
Also es sieht gut aus.
I think so.
Vielleicht noch als letzte Nachfrage. Und denkst du auch, dass sich dort entweder
sowas schon existiert oder vielleicht noch entwickeln könnte,
wie wir das ja auch kennen, so eine aufgeklärte Netzgemeinde,
die auch einen Einfluss auf die Öffentlichkeit nehmen kann?
Die gibt es, die ist nur viel kleiner. Also eines der Einzelprojekte,
was ich mitmache, heißt Alpha Policy.
Und da geht es darum, dass Menschen, die auch gerade in diesen Hubs oder Startups
und so, die ganz oft politische Arbeit machen, aber sich überhaupt nicht politisch
empfinden und es nicht so sehen, einfach eine Lobby bekommen,
ihre Stimme bündeln, um wirklich Policy-Einfluss zu nehmen.
Und zum Beispiel Commercial-Drohnen-Regulierung mit Design und einfach das Anklopfen
bei Rügen an der Tür zu sagen, wir haben die Ahnung,
ihr wollt, dass das Land irgendwie vorankommt, dann lasst uns zusammenarbeiten
und da irgendwie gemeinsam eben Policies zu entwickeln, die für uns funktionieren.
Und das müssten aber noch viel, viel, viel mehr Menschen sein.
Natürlich aufgrund auch unterschiedlicher ökonomischer Gegebenheiten.
Es gibt nicht so viele unkommerzielle Hackerspaces wie bei uns und es gibt nicht
ganz viele Menschen, die sich das auch leisten können, das wirklich ehrenamtlich
zu machen, was ja auch hier bei uns in Deutschland immer noch ein Thema ist,
wie viele Menschen machen ehrenamtlich Netzpolitik in diesem Land
und machen wirklich ganz, ganz wichtige Arbeit, aber es ist einfach nicht deren
Dayjob. Und das ist da natürlich oft noch extremer.
Geraldine, ich könnte jetzt noch Stunden mit dir weiter diskutieren, Aber vielen Dank.
War mir eine große Freude. Ich danke euch.
Ganz kurz die Daten.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß es.
Findet ihr in den Shownotes.
Digital Africa. Und es gibt auch eine Seite, die heißt arte.de slash digitalafrica.
Da gibt man so kleine Clips, die irgendwie mitgedreht wurden.
Und wenn man bei Republika 2018 Digital Africa sucht, ich glaube,
dann wird man auch fündig.
Alright. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Oh Mann, ich habe ja ein Timing heute. Ich probiere es nochmal.
Genau, unser nächster Gast.
Warte mal, ich teste es mal. Warte mal.
Ja.
Haha, kommt gleich.
Sag an.
Ach so, unser nächster Gast ist Jan-Philipp Albrecht.
Genau, so sieht es aus. Applaus Applaus Applaus Applaus Applaus Applaus,
Applaus Ha, hat ein Timing.
Wunderbar, mal gucken, ob es beim nächsten Gast auch noch funktioniert.
Hallo.
Schön, dass du bei uns bist. Wie ja viele Leute gemerkt haben,
war ja gestern ein großer Tag, nämlich der Towel Day.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet alle euer Handtuch dabei.
Ich hatte eins dabei.
Ja, genau. Aber du wolltest ja unbedingt irgendwie umdeuten und den GDPR Day
daraus machen und was soll man sagen, das ist dir gelungen.
Ja, viele wissen das schon, es ist wirklich keine Neuigkeit,
dass du eng mit diesem Thema der neuen Datenschutz-Grundverordnung verbunden
bist, aber bevor wir darauf zu sprechen kommen,
wollen wir erstmal so ein bisschen in der Vergangenheit schürfen,
weil du hast ja irgendwie nicht damit angefangen,
sondern bist ja schon immer sehr politischer Mensch gewesen,
ich glaube, womit hast du so angefangen, grüne Jugend? Ja, genau.
Also ich bin irgendwann mal zu den Grünen gekommen, das waren alle so über 45-Jährige
in meiner Heimatstadt, aber da habe ich dann relativ schnell...
Bei der Grünen Jugend? Bei den Grünen.
Achso, die Grünen Jugend hast du dann gegründet, ne?
Genau, weil das war mir zu alt.
Ja, kann ich verstehen.
Und dann direkt Datenschutz? Nee, ne?
Nee, ich habe dann erstmal einen Baum gepflanzt, wie sich das so von Grünen
gehört und irgendwie dafür geworben, dass mehr Grün in der Stadt ist und gegen
Atommülltransporte demonstriert und all so ein Kram,
den man in Niedersachsen in seiner Jugend macht, wenn man bei den Grünen...
Und dann kam irgendwann Drogenpolitik oder?
Das war ein wichtiges Thema immer bei der Grünen Jugend und war tatsächlich
sogar damals 2002 irgendwie mal so Hauptkampagne in der Bundestagswahlkampf.
Nee, aber hauptsächlich Bürgerrechte dann. Also wie gesagt, dadurch,
dass ich auch viel Demos einfach organisiert habe und viel einfach los war,
war Bürgerrechte und alles, was da drumherum ist, ist erstmal dann Thema.
Und da kam es ziemlich schnell dann zu digitalen Bürgerrechten.
Und damit bist du, du warst mal jüngster Deutscher oder überhaupt Abgeordneter im Europapandemie?
Ja, jüngster Europaabgeordneter aus Deutschland war ich, als ich reinkam.
Mittlerweile gibt es aber viel Jüngere. Finde ich voll cool.
Das war 2009.
Genau.
Wie bist du da reingeraten?
Das ist immer so eine gute Frage, weil das kann man irgendwie nicht so richtig
hundertprozentig planen, obwohl es gibt wahrscheinlich schon Leute,
die das planen können und tun.
Also spätestens, wenn dein Gesicht auf diesen Postern klebt,
dann hast du das wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal geplant.
Genau, also das ist aber wirklich eher so gewesen,
als ich mich engagiert habe bei der Grünen Jugend, zuletzt dann als Sprecher
der Grünen Jugend, da war dann immer so irgendwann die Frage,
ja und, hast du auch mal Bock, das irgendwie so als Job zu machen oder dich
für so ein Mandat zu bewerben?
Und da habe ich immer gesagt, naja, also wenn dann, eigentlich kann ich mir
nur Europaparlament vorstellen, weil das war irgendwie unrealistisch genug,
um das so ein bisschen vom Tisch zu kriegen.
Aber irgendwie steckte da was hinter. Ich hatte irgendwie Bock darauf,
weil das war bei allen Sachen, die wir dann gemacht haben, da ging es auch so
los mit den ganzen Fair-Sharing-Debatten und ja,
natürlich auch Datenschutz, alles mögliche, was wir diskutiert hatten,
war irgendwie klar, müssen wir ins Europaparlament.
Und dann gab es einfach immer mehr Leute, die gesagt haben, klar,
wir brauchen jemanden, der die Themen macht.
Und wir brauchen natürlich auch jüngere Leute in Europa. Und da hatte ich da
auch Bock drauf. Und das haben wir dann irgendwie hinbekommen.
Das war ja die Europawahl, wo die Piraten ihren ersten Achtungserfolg in Deutschland erzielt haben.
Ich erinnere mich da sogar noch an die Meldung. Irgendwie so,
dass dann so, naja, Piraten und irgendwie.
Aber da ist ja noch dieser Jan-Philipp Albrecht, der ist ja jetzt auch dann dazugekommen.
Warst du denn damals eigentlich schon so netzaffin oder bist du mehr von den
Bürgerrechten zum Digitalen gekommen?
Ich war eigentlich erst digital. Als Jugendlicher habe ich eigentlich die ganze
Zeit nur vor Computern abgehangen.
Habe angefangen mit einem C64 und dann so einem Armstrad-PC noch und so ein Kram.
Davon bin ich dann während der Schulzeit weggekommen, weil ich mich bei der
Schülerzeitung engagiert habe und irgendwie Bücher gelesen habe und sowas.
Und dann war ich halt mehr so in dieser politischen Szene und bin dann aber
relativ bald bei der Grünen Jugend wieder zu Digitalisierung,
Netzpolitik zurückgekommen.
Das lag aber vor allen Dingen daran, dass da auch super viele Leute damals bei
dem Thema unterwegs waren.
Hat sich bei der Böllsch-Stiftung damals Netzwerk Neue Medien gegründet,
sind ja auch ein paar Leute, die hier durchaus da mal mit aktiv waren und das
war dann einfach für mich das dominante Thema und das war seit 2003,
2004 eigentlich komplett das Thema.
So, jetzt bist du da aufgeschlagen im Europaplan. Du bist doch auch französischer Staatsbürger.
Ja, meine Großmutter ist Französin. Das erbt man in Frankreich immer so weiter,
die Staatsbürgerschaft.
Also bist du so ein Papier-Franzose, wie so ein Papier-Brite bist.
Okay, aber das macht ja dann trotzdem was im Kopf, oder?
Ja, ja, natürlich. Also meine Großeltern haben auch lange Zeit in Frankreich
gelebt und ich bin häufig da gewesen, auch schon seit Kind.
Deswegen kann ich das auch so ein bisschen nachvollziehen, so in zwei Welten auch aufzuwachsen.
Wobei es bei mir halt nicht so war, dass ich selber in Frankreich gelebt habe.
Aber vielleicht hat das ja die Affinität, auch wenn es erstmal nur eine Ausrede war.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall europäisches Denken oder auch so über die Grenzen hinwegdenken war immer da.
Lag aber auch mit daran, dass ich halt direkt im Zonenrandgebiet gelebt habe
damals, das du als kleines Kind mitbekommen hast.
Und irgendwie war Grenzen und Grenzöffnungen und Rüberdenken bei mir total allgegenwärtig so.
Wie war denn das dann, als du im Parlament aufgeschlagen bist?
Also bläst einem dann gleich der eisige Wind entgegen oder ist das alles total
knuffig und alle haben einen lieb? Also...
Es ist nicht so einfach, sich da durchzusetzen, sodass man dann wirklich die
Möglichkeit hat, da was umzusetzen.
Also das ist so ein bisschen nach Seniorität, auch in den Fraktionen.
Viele Leute, die da sozusagen lang sich so eine Stellung erarbeitet haben,
die haben dann auch meistens die verantwortungsvollen Sachen in der Hand.
Aber da hast du gesagt, du hast schon mal einen Computer eingeschaltet und bist
gleich befördert worden.
Genau, das war mein Trick. Da hatten die alle keine Ahnung von und dann haben
die mir das alles sozusagen mitgegeben. Also man hat sich das auch ein Stück weit erkämpfen müssen.
Aber wenn man mit so ein bisschen Understatement arbeitet, sich nicht darüber
aufregt, dass die Sicherheitsleute ständig nach dem Ausweis fragen und so,
also so typische Erfahrungen, die ja viele andere auch in der Politik jung sind,
erleben, dann kriegt man das auch hin.
Du hast gerade mehr im Nebensatz gesagt, ja, es war irgendwie klar,
auf jeden Fall EU-Parlament.
Hast das aber dann eigentlich mit politischer Strategie und den Themen begründet.
Im EU-Parlament läuft es ja schon irgendwie ein bisschen anders als im Deutschen Bundestag.
Wusstest du das? Also hattest du da eine Ahnung von, in welche Umgebung du dich da begibst? Oder ...
Ich war vorher Praktikant im Europaparlament, deswegen kannte ich den Laden
dann so ein bisschen für ein paar Monate.
Während meines Erasmus-Semesters habe ich das so drangehangen und das fand ich
auf jeden Fall spannend, das hat mich sehr beeindruckt und ich kannte zum Beispiel
auch die Arbeit im Bundestag,
weil ich da über meine Position bei der Grünen Jugend öfter mal so in den Sitzungen war.
Und für mich hat das Europaparlament von der Art und Weise, wie es gearbeitet hat,
eine große Anziehung gehabt, weil es einfach nicht dieses, jeder sitzt in seiner
Fraktion und die anderen sind doof und überhaupt lehnt die Opposition alles
ab, was die Regierung macht und die Regierung macht nur das, was,
oder die Fraktionen der Regierung machen nur das, was die Minister sagen.
Das ist im MEP halt anders. Da machst du jedes Mal eine neue Koalitionsverhandlung,
wenn da ein neuer Gesetzentwurf kommt. Und das finde ich voll spannend.
Gibt es völlig unterschiedliche Mehrheiten, wechselnde Mehrheiten und man geht
doch relativ kollegial miteinander um.
Liegt aber natürlich auch so ein bisschen daran, dass die Öffentlichkeit vielleicht
nicht so medial krass drauf guckt, wie was im Bundestag passiert.
Und vielleicht auch daran, dass es nicht so viel Power hat.
Ja, dass die Leute denken, dass es nicht so viel Power hat.
Ah, hat es?
Ja.
Hast du mal Internet aufgemacht? Kannst du Power des EU-Parlamentes sehen?
Ich kann das total verstehen, dass viele Leute das immer noch nicht so richtig
nachvollziehen können, wenn man sagt, wieso, das EU-Parlament hat doch eigentlich
nichts zu sagen. Das ist dann die eigentliche Reaktion.
Aber es stimmt mittlerweile nicht mehr. Also mit dem Vertrag von Lissabon 2009,
der hat sicherlich auch ganz viele Schwächen, aber es ist eine Sache deutlich
besser geworden und das ist die Beteiligung, die Macht des Parlaments.
Die ist mittlerweile fast sozusagen umfassend als Gesetzgeber.
Es muss immer noch jedes EU-Gesetz sowohl vom Parlament als auch von den Mitgliedstaaten
verabschiedet werden, nicht so wie im Bundestag, wo viele Gesetze auch ohne
den Bundesrat mal durchgebracht werden können.
Aber es muss alles mitentschieden werden. Deswegen hat es schon große Macht.
Und wenn man sich das überlegt, was für Gesetze da mittlerweile verabschiedet
werden, Stichwort DSGVO, es gehört zu den wichtigsten Positionen,
die wir zu vergeben haben als Wahlvolk.
So, genau. Jetzt kommen wir da langsam so hin. Irgendwann bist du dann in den
Innenausschuss. Oder war das von Anfang an da?
Genau. Ich war immer im Innen- und Justizausschuss, weil alle Bürgerrechtsthemen
und der Datenschutz und auch so Sachen wie Rechtsextremismusbekämpfung,
die ich halt auch gemacht habe, so alles war da drin.
Und dann gibt es da so einen Ausschuss, den man zusätzlich nimmt.
Als stellvertretendes Mitglied, da war ich im Rechtsausschuss und im Binnenmarktausschuss,
aber meistens war das sozusagen mein Thema Bürgerrechte.
Genau, aber dann bist du in der zweiten Legislatur zum stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden geworden.
Warum? Wieso haben die dich das machen lassen? Dem musst du doch klar sein,
wen die sich da reinholen.
Das ist so ähnlich wie im Bundestag, auch in den Landtagen, glaube ich,
dass das verteilt wird nach Fraktionen.
Das sind so Posten, die halt dann zusätzlich vergeben werden,
damit man dann von den Fraktionen auch so ein bisschen Einfluss darauf hat,
was für eine Tagesordnung da aufgesetzt wird und wer die Sitzung leitet und so weiter.
Und das habe ich von meiner Fraktion sozusagen. Mach du mal.
Und war das dann von vornherein klar, dass so eine neue Datenschutzregelung auf dem Tisch liegt?
Ich meine, es gibt ja auch eine sehr langfristige Planung eigentlich so europäischen Maßstabs.
Da gibt es ja diese großen Blätter, die man so auffalten kann und so,
oh, was wir in den nächsten 20 Jahren alles so vorhaben.
Oder hast du das auf die Art Gänge gesetzt?
Nee, das war relativ plötzlich. Vor ein paar Wochen haben wir das Ding verabschiedet.
Nee, ich warte, zum Beginn deiner zweiten Legislaturperiode.
Also die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, diese Datenschutzreform,
die haben wir im Grunde genommen angefangen zu diskutieren, da bin ich gerade
das erste Mal gewählt worden.
Also es ist mittlerweile echt neun Jahre her, dass das losging.
Es lag auch zum Teil am Lissabon-Vertrag, weil der Datenschutz als Grundrecht,
genauso wie die Informationsfreiheit und viele andere Grundrechte,
da verbindlich durch die Grundrechtekarte der Europäischen Union niedergelegt
wurde und klar war, das muss jetzt auch gesetzgeberisch dann entsprechend umgesetzt werden.
Aber die eigentliche Arbeit daran, die war dann halt jetzt zwischen 2012 und
2016, als wir das dann verabschiedet haben.
Und die haben, also du hast dein Team und dann hast du immer gesagt, übrigens,
ich habe nicht aufgepasst und habe uns ein riesiges Paket Arbeit eingetreten
oder war das schon ganz klar, dass ihr das auch wolltet mit dem Team,
was du aufgestellt hast,
war ja wahrscheinlich relativ klar, dass ihr da auch drauf hingearbeitet habt,
diese Aufgabe zu bekommen, oder?
Absolut. Ich bin ja auch reingegangen mit dem Vorhaben, wir wollen jetzt sozusagen
die Bürgerrechte im Digitalen stärken, Überwachung verhindern und Datenschutz
stärken und als das dann aufkam, dass diese Reform stattfindet,
war für uns so, okay, da werden wir auf jeden Fall mitmachen,
aber dass das dann tatsächlich der Job als Verhandlungsführer sein würde,
das war nicht wirklich klar.
Aber in dem Moment, wo es auf dem Tisch lag, haben wir da also dann eine Nacht
zusammengesessen und überlegt, boah krass, machen wir das jetzt wirklich?
Weil war klar, dass das einfach unfassbar viel Arbeit ist und man kann sich
natürlich auch einfach die Arbeit leicht machen und sagen, ich labere nur rum als Politiker.
Kommen auch gut mit durch, aber wir wollten es verändern.
Mit wir meinst du dich und vor allem Ralf Benrath.
Den wir auch schon zu Gast hatten.
Aber noch ein größeres Team?
Das ganze andere Team, alle zusammen, hatten dann auch gesagt,
okay, nee, das machen wir dann natürlich.
Und da war auch klar, dass das Jahre dauern würde.
Ja, das war absehbar, aber damals gab es die große Vorstellung von allen möglichen,
auch der EU-Kommission, das verabschieden wir bis zur Europawahl 2014.
Damals war sich auch alle sicher, schaffen wir, läuft.
Und es gibt ja auch so einen Dokumentarfilm darüber, es sind ja auch Arte Leute,
die das gemacht haben, über diese Entstehung.
Und die haben ja so eine Langzeit-Doku gemacht. Und die haben gesagt,
ja, ja, also mach mal los. Und in anderthalb Jahren haben wir es fertig.
Dann könnt ihr euren Film da fertig machen.
Und am Ende haben die da irgendwie drei Jahre mit uns abgehangen und mussten
dann immer nochmal wiederkommen.
Und es hat noch viel länger gedauert. Also das ist ja jetzt letztendlich auch
erst gestern dann zur Anwendung gekommen.
Der Film heißt Democracy im Rausch der Daten und lief, glaube ich,
vorgestern Abend, oder? Das heißt, den kann man sich gerade noch in irgendeiner
Mediathek wahrscheinlich anschauen.
So ist es.
Das war ein sehr schöner Film.
Genau, weil ja nun gestern so dieser Stichtag war, der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung,
die ja im Prinzip so eigentlich zumindest in Deutschland auch schon existiert hat, nur ab jetzt…,
Und alle haben Angst.
Jetzt ist es ernst.
Also ich fand es fantastisch, diese Reaktionswelle zu beobachten.
Was mich am meisten beeindruckt hat eigentlich zuerst, war, dass es an einem
Ort diskutiert wurde, mit dem ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so richtig gerechnet hatte.
Nämlich bevor das hier so richtig losgehypt war, hörte ich das schon auch in
vielen Podcasts, zum Beispiel in den USA, die alle so, oh, war ja hier die Europäer,
die machen aber jetzt hier was und so. Und da müssen wir ja aber mal richtig nachdenken.
Das fand ich bemerkenswert und habe es dann auch so ein bisschen aus dieser
Perspektive verfolgt und so ein bisschen das Gefühl bekommen,
aber vielleicht übersehe ich jetzt auch noch irgendwas, aber das kannst du ja
mal bestätigen oder bestreiten,
dass das in gewisser Hinsicht jetzt so eine Reglementierung ist,
die so eine enorme globale Auswirkung auch zu haben scheint,
dass sich da komplett andere Länder und andere Jurisdiktionen mindestens damit
beschäftigen müssen, wenn nicht sogar versuchen, sich dazu konkret zu verhalten.
Ja, also es ist auch tatsächlich eine Wirkung, wenn man sie jetzt mal,
blenden wir mal die deutsche Debatte so ein bisschen aus, aber wenn man die
globale Debatte gerade anschaut, eine Wirkung, die wir so gar nicht erwartet hätten.
Was passiert tatsächlich ist, dass in einigen Ländern der Welt,
heute habe ich gehört, Israel zum Beispiel auch, in Japan ist es auch so,
die Gesetze jetzt sozusagen so formuliert werden, wie wir sie als Europäer formuliert haben,
weil die den Zugang zum Markt haben wollen, nach Europa, wir haben einen unglaublich
großen Markt, mit dem wir natürlich viel bestimmen können und die Unternehmen
eh sagen, wir richten uns nach dem Standard der Europäer, weil das ist für uns
der viel maßgeblichere Markt.
Und das passiert halt jetzt tatsächlich. Und heute habe ich in der Washington
Post auch einen Artikel gelesen, also der größte Tech-Regulator im Moment ist Europa.
Also der Blick ist wirklich auch ein Stück weit ein anderer als innerhalb Europas,
wo wir natürlich jetzt erstmal uns damit auseinandersetzen, dass wir den Datenschutz
jetzt ja natürlich wirklich ernst meinen als Europäer und sich alle so ein bisschen
natürlich da mit so einer Zumutung konfrontiert sehen.
Über die Zumutung wurde viel gequengelt. Also ich muss meinen Blog jetzt zumachen.
Also ich habe auch gestern, das habe ich mir auch für den Tag aufbewahrt,
habe ich noch ein paar Wordpresses gefixt.
Und ich muss sagen, da habe ich mich auf jeden Fall sehr geärgert,
dass die überhaupt so einen Mist gemacht haben, diese Blogs.
Also es gab auch wirklich einfach keinen Grund.
Also das Ärgerliche war wegen dir und Ralf und euch allen da und wegen der EU
musste ich jetzt irgendwie in diesem PHP-Code irgendwie rumwühlen und die völlig
unnötigen Cookies finden und so, damit ich keine Cookie-Warnung habe.
Ja, fand ich ganz schlimm. So, warum habt ihr das gemacht?
Damit die alten Cookies da mal wegkommen. Schimmeln ja nur.
Nee, also das haben wir gemacht, weil letztendlich.
Wirklich über Jahre hinweg die große Mehrheit der Leute gesagt hat,
also das ist irgendwie ein Quatsch, dass wir zwar Regeln haben,
aber die werden in der Praxis nicht durchgesetzt.
Und natürlich haben wir das vor allen Dingen mit Blick auf viele große Anbieter
gesagt, bei denen offensichtlich war, dass die Müll machen.
Und das ist ja auch immer noch so. Und wenn wir jetzt darüber reden,
dass alles besser wird mit der Dantomsgrundverordnung, dann ist an Tag eins
natürlich immer noch ziemlich viel falsch.
Nur etwas sich jetzt ändert, ist, dass diejenigen, die sagen,
pass auf, ich habe aber das Recht, dass ihr das und das macht.
Jetzt einen Hebel in der Hand haben.
Die können dagegen klagen, die haben ordentliche Sanktionssummen,
die sie da mobilisieren können.
Und das ist für Leute wie Max Schrems oder andere, die das jetzt auch hervorbereiten,
echt Gold wert, weil sie diese Rechte durchsetzen können.
Das heißt aber übrigens nicht, dass man das unbedingt überall muss.
Und diese Panik vor den Blockwartanwälten, die da sozusagen rüberkommen und
mir eine Abmahnung schicken,
die ist meines Erachtens wirklich übertrieben, weil sie zwar da ist,
in Deutschland übrigens nur, in allen anderen EU-Ländern gibt es das nicht so,
dass man bei der ersten Abmahnung da so eine Gebühr nehmen darf.
Aber in aller Regel wird es niemanden geben, der diese Anwälte dafür mandatiert.
Und das ist immer notwendig, dass es da ein Mandat sozusagen hintergibt.
Und das hätte es auch unter dem jetzigen Datenschutzrecht gegeben.
Es gibt aber viel bessere Regeln wie Urheberrecht oder so, mit denen man natürlich
viel lukrativer abmachen kann.
Aber sagst du, dass das dann quasi unmöglich ist?
Nee, unmöglich ist das nicht. Aber wie gesagt, es ist möglich in allen möglichen Rechtsbereichen.
Ich halte das auch für Quatsch in Deutschland, dass das so möglich ist.
Sollte man auf jeden Fall reformieren, finde die Debatte richtig.
Aber es kommt halt nicht durch die Datenschutzverordnung. Durch die Datenschutzverordnung
kommt diese Zumutung, dass du halt deine Cookies aufräumen musst und den Leuten
an einer Stelle auch reinen Wein einschenken musst, wenn du tatsächlich über sie was erheben willst.
Und das ist es.
Aber das ist ja einer der Hauptkritikpunkte, die jetzt so an die DSGVO herangetragen
werden, nämlich dass die Regeln im Prinzip für alle die gleichen sind.
Also wenn ich Daten verarbeiten würde, müsste ich dabei genauso viel informieren,
Rechte bereitstellen für Menschen wie Google oder Facebook.
Und du hast gerade auch gesagt, dass ihr primär solche Tech-Giganten im Auge
hattet, weil das natürlich diejenigen sind, die gegen das Datenschutzrecht verstoßen
haben. Warum war es notwendig?
Nicht zum Beispiel zu sagen, okay, wir ziehen Grenzen ein und sagen,
erst ab, so und so viel für Kleinunternehmer und Hobbyblogger und Instagram-Influencer
machen wir nochmal andere Regeln.
Ja, weil das würde den Datenschutz, wie wir ihn heute haben, extrem reduzieren.
Also weil es eigentlich ein Grundrecht ist, gilt das Recht zum Beispiel auf
Auskunft über meine Daten natürlich generell. Nicht nur gegenüber bestimmten
Unternehmen oder auch nicht nur gegenüber Behörden.
Es war auch eine unterschiedliche Art und Weise, wie es gegenüber dem Staat und dem Privaten gilt.
Aber am Ende sind es meine Daten und bei denen ist völlig egal,
wo die rumliegen. Das Risiko ist damit verbunden.
Und das ist wie bei der IT-Sicherheit so.
Da nur drauf zu gucken, dass die großen Unternehmen alles fixen,
macht überhaupt keinen Sinn, wenn alle dann mit ihrer...
Super unsicheren Technologie überall reinlatschen und schwächere Links erzeugen.
Das ist natürlich auch immer nur nicht 100% vergleichbar, aber letztendlich steht das dahinter.
Der Gedanke, es ist ein Grundrecht, also sollte es überall gelten.
Es stimmt aber auch nicht, dass das alles gleich behandelt wird.
Im Gegenteil, in der jetzigen Rechtslage gibt es zum Beispiel,
was die Sanktionen angeht, nur bis zu 300.000 Euro.
Das ist überhaupt nicht verhältnismäßig zu sagen, Pass auf, also dem riesen
milliardenschweren Unternehmen droht maximal genau so eine Strafe wie allen anderen.
Und jetzt knüpfen wir das an den Umsatz bei diesen Unternehmen und haben damit
eine ganz andere Art der Bestrafung.
Und bei denjenigen, die überhaupt keine Gewinnerzielungsabsicht und so weiter haben,
da ist es so, dass den Aufsichtsbehörden schon heute, aber erst recht in der
Datenschutzgrundverordnung auferlegt
wird, nur verhältnismäßig gegen die vorzugehen, gegen alle vorzugehen.
Und das wäre völlig unverhältnismäßig, wenn du da ein Cookie zu viel drauf hast
oder so, da eine Strafe zu verhängen.
Sondern die Leute, ja, okay, gut, ich wollte schon melden,
also da wird letztendlich, wenn die überhaupt Zeit dafür haben,
Hilfe geleistet, ja, und also ich glaube, man darf das nicht zu heiß kochen,
das ist einfach eine Grundregel, ja, es ist wie ein Knigger fürs Digitale,
ja, man hält sich einfach dran und für uns alle ist das ein bisschen eine Zumutung, ja,
weil wir alle irgendwie so ein bisschen auch Datenschutz-Schluffis sind,
so, ja, in mancher Umgebung.
Trotzdem finden wir es aber trotzdem richtig, wenn wir selber betroffen sind.
Wir wollen nicht, dass jemand einfach so alles mögliche bei uns speichert,
ohne uns zumindest einmal Bescheid gesagt zu haben. Und darum geht es letztendlich.
Da fällt mir die Schufa ein. Die speichern alles mögliche über alle möglichen
Leute und haben mir jetzt auch nicht immer Bescheid gesagt. Also sie sagen mir
nur Bescheid, wenn ich nachfrage.
Hast du jetzt keine Mail bekommen?
Wenn Sie weiter von uns Kredit-Tradings erhalten wollen, willigen Sie bitte jetzt ein.
Auf Twitter habe ich Mossad gesehen, war auch gut.
Was macht man, also welche Regeln kann ich jetzt gegenüber, also wann macht
die Schufa dicht eigentlich, war die Frage.
Ich glaube, die werden es schon schwer haben. Also die bauen halt bisher darauf
tatsächlich in so einem Graubereich dieser Aussage, naja, das ist ja zur Durchsetzung
von irgendwelchen Interessen, aber es ist eigentlich eine präventive Geschichte.
Und das geht so weit in das Vorfeld, dass man echt denkt, das sind halt Privatdetektive,
die aber eigentlich überhaupt kein eigenes Interesse oder kein besonderes Interesse daran haben.
Ich glaube, dass sie es unglaublich schwer haben werden, jedenfalls so, wie sie es jetzt machen.
Die Transparenzfrage ist absolut offen und in der Datenschutzgrundverordnung
steht zum Beispiel auch eine neue Bestimmung, dass in solchen Fällen Informationen
über die Logik hinter automatisierten Verarbeitungen veröffentlicht werden müssen.
Da also eine lange Debatte, die wir mit der Schufa haben, dass sie endlich mal
offenlegen, nach welchen Kriterien sie zum Beispiel Scoring betreiben,
das werden sie wohl so nicht mehr weitermachen können wie bisher.
Was heißt wohl?
Naja, wohl heißt, jemand muss sie erst zum Jagen tragen.
Also wo kein Kläger, da kein Richter. Das ist ja auch, wie gesagt,
der Punkt, der ein Segen ist, weil eben nicht jeder ständig überall ermahnt wird.
Aber in Fällen der Schuhfahrt, glaube ich, wird es da jemanden geben.
Das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen.
Weil das Problem ist, wie sollen sich Schufa-Kritiker das leisten,
wenn die anfangen Geld zu sammeln, wird das ja eh gefändig.
Die kriegen erstmal schlechte Scoring. Dann kriegen die keinen Anwalt, genau.
Dafür gibt es Verbraucherschutzorganisationen, die werden übrigens auch gestärkt
in ihrer Stellung und der Möglichkeit für die Verbraucher zu klagen.
Wie genau?
Sammelklagen zum Beispiel.
Ist das dann ein schönes Class-Action, wie man es aus den USA kennt,
die MacBook-Tastatur klemmt, zack.
Ja, tatsächlich geht das in diese Richtung, nur dass wir natürlich nicht mit
diesen krassen Summen arbeiten,
die da möglicherweise dann bei so einem Gerichtsverfahren auf dem Spiel stehen,
bei so Schäden zum Beispiel, die eingetreten sind.
Aber was auch neu ist, es gibt tatsächlich einen Schadensersatzanspruch auch
und das gab es bisher nicht, haben wir immer eine lange Diskussion darüber gehabt,
wenn ich mich halt dann wirklich mal irgendwann durchsetze gegen irgendwie Sony,
Playstation, Network oder so, dass die da meine Daten irgendwie verloren haben,
weil Kreditkartendaten dabei waren oder so, dann war das eigentlich meistens
dann nur, okay, was kann ich gewinnen, dass die sagen, die Gerichte,
nee, nee, nee, darfst du aber nicht oder vielleicht ein Ordnungsgeld verhängen.
Aber was ich jetzt machen kann, ich kann auf Entschädigung klagen und das finde ich relativ wichtig.
Es wird zumindest sozusagen in so einer Schmerzensgeldart gehandhabt,
weil es natürlich unglaublich schwer nachzuweisen ist, wenn ich Daten irgendwie
anders benutzt habe, dass dadurch ein wirtschaftlicher Schaden eingetreten ist.
Wie ist das mit dem, mit dieser Einwilligung durch nichts tun?
Also es war ja sehr schön in der letzten Woche zu beobachten,
alle schicken diese GDPR-Mails, wären natürlich auch die Fischer und Scammer.
Irgendwie so klicken sie hier und wenn sie diese Mails noch weiterbekommen wollen,
nicht weiterbekommen wollen.
War es so, dass man bis Donnerstag noch solche Mails, wenn sie jetzt nichts
tun, werden wir das als Zustimmung und ab Freitag nicht mehr schicken durfte?
Ich habe eine E-Mail bekommen, da stand irgendwie in Betreff GDPR sucks,
but please give us your consent.
Das fand ich ganz lustig, habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Das mit dem Link hilft übrigens auch nicht. Also ich habe so jemanden gesehen,
der sich gewundert, dass kurz nachdem er die Mail bekommen hat,
ob er denn zustimmen möchte, gleich die Mail bekommen hat,
dass er sich bedanken, dass er zugestimmt hat und dann rauszufinden,
dass der Virus-Scanner automatisch alle Links aufgelöst hat.
Das ist natürlich auch super.
Also es muss natürlich niemand alle jetzt nochmal fragen, ob man zum Beispiel
auf Newsletter will, wenn die schon drauf sind, wenn man dokumentiert hat,
dass die schon mal eingewildert haben. Und da fängt es halt schon wieder an.
Wenn man mal so ehrlich zu sich ist, dann sind in den meisten Newsletterlisten
halt dann doch irgendwo Leute drin, bei denen man eigentlich weiß,
naja, die habe ich eigentlich nur so draufgeschrieben.
Und in dem Moment, wo ich das aber nicht identifizieren kann,
haben diese in den meisten Fällen halt Unternehmen dann das Problem,
die müssen auf Nummer sicher gehen, also fragen sie lieber alle,
dass sie nochmal neu einwilligen, dann verlieren sie natürlich viele.
Wie kann man denn diesen Prozess überhaupt beweisen? Also ich meine,
man kann ja immer sagen, da hat der Viruskenner draufgeklickt.
Deswegen ist das, es ist immer noch alles so, dass das jetzt auch kein Hexenwerk
ist. Man muss es halt dokumentieren, wenn man es ordentlich dokumentiert hat natürlich.
Also ich meine, du kannst die Behörden natürlich auch belügen,
weil habe ich natürlich alles schon dokumentiert, hier ist die Liste.
Aber zumindest das zu machen. Wer das nicht macht, der hat halt dann ein Problem
und das ist der Schutz, den für die Verbraucher gegeben ist durch die neue Regelung
und ich glaube auch ehrlich gesagt,
dass das für viele wirklich eine Befreiung ist, zumindest zu wissen,
alles klar, ich habe irgendwie in der Vergangenheit auch ein bisschen naiv überall
so vielleicht meine Daten irgendwo abgegeben und irgendwas zugewilligt und so
und jetzt wird sich das vielleicht ein bisschen ändern.
Also ich glaube, die Debatte trägt dazu bei, dass wir alle irgendwie in eine
neue Art von Umgang damit eintreten.
Ich glaube, anzunehmen, dass jetzt alles total super gelaufen ist, geht auch nicht.
Ich höre aus verschiedensten Stellen, kann das aber jetzt gar nicht so richtig
qualifizieren, so ja, Datenschutz, die Ziele, alles super, aber wir haben uns
das mal so im Detail durchgelesen und es ist irgendwie alles ein bisschen unklar.
Also es gibt so diesen Vorwurf der unklaren Definition.
Dem stimmst du wahrscheinlich ein bisschen teilen zu.
Ja, dem stimme ich zu, aber dazu muss ich was sagen, weil manchmal sind wir
ja, und da müssen politische Prozesse vielleicht auch besser erklärt werden,
wir sind nicht so ganz in der Lage zu verstehen, was da passiert.
Wenn wir ein europäisches Gesetz machen, damit wir gemeinsam als Europäer unsere
Regeln und Werte nach außen besser durchsetzen können, Dann kann natürlich danach,
wenn das Gesetz dann da ist und die nationalen Gesetze ersetzt,
damit wir eine einheitliche Rechtsordnung haben,
das neue EU-Recht nicht genauso aussehen wie das Recht eines Mitgliedstaats.
Auch wenn Deutschland das größte, wichtigste, tollste Land, was weiß ich,
in Europa ist, kann es nicht beanspruchen, dass danach alles genauso aussieht,
wie es vorher bei Ihnen zu Hause aussah.
Und die anderen haben eben auch eine jahrhundertealte Rechtskultur.
Die benutzen unterschiedliche Begriffe. Das sind 24 unterschiedliche Sprachen.
Wir einigen uns da auf einen Kompromiss in der Sache.
Aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es für immer so bleiben muss. Im Gegenteil,
es wird sehr, sehr viele Verfahren geben, es gibt viele tolle Kommentare und Auslegungen.
Und irgendwann wird dann auch der Europäische Gerichtshof dann mal gesagt haben, wie es aussieht.
Und es ist ja nicht so, dass wir in deutschen Gesetzen nicht auch überall genug
Stoff haben für Juristen, tagtäglich darüber viele Meinungen zu haben.
Ja, also da ist ja schon ein einziges Adjektiv können sich, glaube ich,
so die Rechtsgelärten...
Deswegen kann ich die Unsicherheit verstehen und sie ist auch da,
aber sie wird eben Stück für Stück auch beseitigt werden und die Hauptaufgabe
dabei liegt im Moment bei den Datenschutzbehörden.
Und die müssen sich nämlich europaweit jetzt auch zusammensetzen und entsprechende Empfehlungen geben.
Und in denen kann man dann auch nachlesen, wie es genau auszulegen ist.
Ja, die Dinge kommen auf jeden Fall in Bewegung. Also ich glaube,
das lässt sich überhaupt nicht bestreiten und ich finde das ganz gut,
weil lange Zeit, glaube ich, so Datenschutz auch immer so ein bisschen wie so eine Chimäre,
gerade in Deutschland so vor sich hergetragen wurde, ja, Datenschutz irgendwie
voll super und so, aber so richtig konkret ist es jetzt noch nicht geworden
und manche wimmern halt jetzt so, oh Gott, jetzt muss man auch wirklich mal was tun.
Damit will ich nicht sagen, dass die Leute, die es nicht auch schwer damit zu kämpfen haben.
Ja, es ist eine Zumutung.
Aber eine gute Zumutung.
Genau, es ist eine gute Zumutung, aber es gibt natürlich jetzt Vereine und so
weiter, mit verschiedenen Strukturen und gewachsenen Systemen etc.,
die da schwer zu kämpfen haben.
Der CCC hat jetzt eine Datenschutzbeauftragte. War nicht schwer zu finden in dem Verein.
Sogar wir haben.
Hast du noch was zur Grundverordnung?
Zu den Begriffen, es gibt ja eine, also ich habe natürlich jetzt viel dazu gelesen, eine,
das strukturiert abgelegte Daten und es kursiert irgendwie die Behauptung oder
das Phänomen oder der Gag, dass wenn ich Visitenkarten sortiert aufbewahre,
dann sind sie strukturiert, dann fallen sie unter eine andere,
also ich sollte möglichst den Visitenkarten,
Stapel mischen, damit der nicht mehr strukturiert ist und ich darüber keine Auskunft geben muss.
Das ist eine dieser sehr lustigen Auswüchse dieser Debatte, weil der Datenschutz
in Europa auch heute schon bezieht sich nur auf elektronisch verarbeitete,
also digital verarbeitete Daten.
Alles, was irgendwer auf dem Papier schreibt oder vorhin der Witz da mit Namensschild
und so, das fällt einfach nicht unter den Datenschutz.
Das ist rein nur Persönlichkeitsrechte, die dann anwendbar sind.
Datenschutz ist für elektronisch verarbeitetes.
Jetzt haben wir über all das geredet. Eine letzte Frage zum Datenschutz.
Warum haben wir überhaupt Datenschutz? Warum gibt es denn überhaupt?
Wir haben nur kluge Hörer und Hörerinnen, die Hörerinnen sowieso sind viel klüger.
Aber warum sagst du, gibt es Datenschutz? Also würde mich echt interessieren,
warum sagst du, warum ist das ein Phänomen, was dich interessiert?
Es geht um Würde und Freiheit und die stehen in unserer Rechtsordnung relativ
weit oben aus guten Gründen und wir brauchen letztendlich ein paar Schutzregeln,
um Würde und Freiheit tatsächlich zu gewährleisten und auch Gleichbehandlung,
das ist auch ein Ausdruck, finde ich, von Menschenwürde und.
Das, was sich daraus ergibt, ist letztendlich, dass ich als Person ein Stück
weit darüber auch selber bestimmen können muss, wie ich als Person mich gebe, wer ich sein will.
Das ist meine Persönlichkeit, die ich selber entwickle. Und das kann ich nicht,
wenn alle möglichen Daten von mir
in irgendwelchen völlig unsteuerbaren Zusammenhängen verarbeitet werden.
Und ich kann dann auch nicht mehr darauf vertrauen, dass es so etwas gibt wie
eine Gleichbehandlung, weil wir alle ungleich sind und gerade da fängt es beim
Datenschutz an, heute sehr relevant zu werden,
weil Diskriminierung und Ungleichbehandlung ganz viel jetzt darauf fußt,
dass eben nicht ungerechtfertigt diskriminiert wird,
sondern die sagen, es ist gerechtfertigt, weil wir wissen alles über euch und
deswegen wissen wir natürlich auch, dass das okay ist, zwischen euch zu diskriminieren,
ihr seid einfach ganz unterschiedlich einzuschätzen.
Es geht bis dahin, dass irgendwie Ablebezeiträume vorausgesagt werden können
und so mit irgendwelchen Gesundheitsdaten, die da erhoben werden.
Und ich glaube, da müssen wir darauf drängen, dass wir selber immer noch zumindest
als Gesellschaft die Kontrolle haben, das zu steuern, zu sagen,
was soll in welchen Situationen verarbeitet werden und was vielleicht eher nicht über uns.
Ablebe-Zeiträume. Schönes Wort.
Haben wir ein Sendungsziel.
Ich bin gerade ausgedacht.
Ich finde das interessant, dass du bei Würde und Freiheit bist.
Mein Hauptargument für Datenschutz ist einfach Macht.
Hat ja aber was mit Freiheit zu tun. Freiheit ist eigentlich total eng gekoppelt zum Machtthema.
Emanzipatives Das Dasein von Menschen hängt halt total viel mit Selbstbestimmung,
also Freiheit zur Selbstbestimmung zusammen.
Und ich glaube, es ist nicht ganz abwegig oder überraschend,
dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht damals dieses Monster-Wort informationelle
Selbstbestimmung irgendwie entworfen hat.
Da ist irgendwie was dran, auch wenn das natürlich ein bisschen und auch das
Wort Datenschutz natürlich einfach nicht treffend ist. Es geht nicht darum,
die Datenschutz schützen.
Es geht darum, uns Menschen ein bisschen vor uns zu schützen.
Das ist ein Menschenrecht.
So ist es. Ist auch ein Menschenrecht.
Rechtlich ist es ein Menschenrecht.
Und was denkst du, was so, also ist es jetzt irgendwie Haken drunter,
jetzt Datenschutz haben wir?
Oder mal abgesehen jetzt von der, von der, von dieser Phase,
in der sich jetzt quasi diese konkrete Verordnung erstmal manifestieren muss.
Denkst du, es gibt da noch so einen nächsten Level, den man noch erreichen muss,
der jetzt noch überhaupt nicht adressiert wurde? Auf jeden Fall. Welcher ist das dann?
Also ich sage mal, mit der Datenschutzgrundverordnung haben wir etwas gefixt,
was sowieso total problematisch war in der Vergangenheit.
Es ist aber noch lange nicht wirklich der große Schritt voran bei vielen Fragen.
Also es ist ein wichtiger Schritt, aber ein erster in einem ganzen Marathon
an Schritten, den wir noch gehen müssen, um uns mit unseren Werten an die digitalisierte,
Gegenwart und Zukunft anzupassen mit unseren Gesetzen,
und beim Datenschutz zum Beispiel oder alles, was so mit Überwachung und Selbstbestimmung
zu tun hat, sehe ich total, dass wir darüber reden müssen, wie wir damit umgehen,
wenn draußen da überall selbstfahrende Autos fahren oder sonst was.
Flugtaxis kommen auch.
Flugtaxis, die haben dann plötzlich alle Kameras und so, das kann ja gar nicht
mehr funktionieren, dass dann alle ständig einwilligen, also werden wir darüber diskutieren.
Wir werden darüber diskutieren, ob ob das in Ordnung ist, dass da ständig überall
alles mitgefilmt wird oder so oder Daten erhoben werden, wenn wir irgendwie Google Glass haben.
Also die Debatte ist lange nicht zu Ende, die wird weitergehen.
Und ich glaube auch, ehrlich gesagt, Datenschutz ist ja auch nur ein Baustein
von so vielen, wenn wir über Grund- und Menschenrechte in der Digitalisierung
reden oder wenn wir überhaupt das Zusammenleben in der Digitalisierung reden.
Und da sind die Baustellen fast unermesslich. Also wir müssen darüber reden,
welche ethischen Rahmenbedingungen in der weiteren Entwicklung,
von künstlicher Intelligenz, Robotik, Machine Learning stattfinden sollen,
wie wir das überhaupt fördern wollen.
Ist das nur Bildung? Sind das Regeln, Standards und so weiter?
Wir müssen darüber reden, wie unsere Arbeitswelt verändert wird.
All diese ganzen Debatten, ihr kennt das alles.
Insofern will ich da jetzt nicht ins Lava kommen. Also ich glaube einfach,
dass da wirklich, da ist ein riesen Aufholbedarf.
Stichwort nur IT-Sicherheit. Ich meine, was für einen krassen Schrott wir auf
dem Markt haben und es gibt überhaupt keinen richtigen Standard dafür.
Das ist eine Riesenlücke. Wir haben alles mögliche für Produkte,
dass der Tisch irgendwie nicht umfallen darf oder so und solche Sachen.
Aber wenn es darum geht, irgendwie ordentliche Passwörter oder Verschlüsselungsanforderungen
zu formulieren oder Patch-Verpflichtungen irgendwie aufzuerlegen,
das gibt es alles nicht. so, ne?
Aber jetzt bleibst du nicht.
Netzpolitik berichtete.
Jetzt bleibst du aber nicht im EU-Parlament, um uns die ITS-GVO,
die IT-Sicherheitsgrundverordnung noch kurz fertig zu machen.
Sondern wir sind fahnenflüchtig jetzt sozusagen.
Gibt es gerade die ENISA-Verordnung in der, also könnt ihr auch mal machen,
ENISA-Verordnung. Das ist auf jeden Fall wichtig.
ENISA?
Läuft gerade das Verfahren. Und da geht es halt um Zertifizierung und Standards
im Bereich IT-Sicherheit.
Leider auch nur ein erster kleiner Wurf, weil wirklich Standards sind da nicht drin.
Sie müssten ja nur Haftung reinschreiben.
Genau, und das ist die große Debatte, die dann auch kommt und da haben wir natürlich viel gedrängt.
Tatsächlich, ich habe jetzt nach neun Jahren beschlossen, aus der Europapolitik
mal rauszugehen, wieder hier in Deutschland vor Ort regional Politik zu machen,
aber ich bin deswegen nicht weg von der Digitalisierung, im Gegenteil und das
darf ich da tatsächlich als Minister machen.
Genau, und zwar, wenn ich das mal zitieren darf, wirst du jetzt die Nachfolge
antreten von Robert Habeck, der nämlich derzeit noch der Minister ist im Ministerium für, Achtung,
Energiewende, Landwirtschaft,
Umwelt, Natur und Digitalisierung des Landes Schleswig-Holstein.
Genau, fehlt eigentlich nur noch.
Melund.
Melund, genau.
Ich bin auch hier ein paar Waldtraum.
Dann wäre es wirklich komplett, aber ich habe mir das so angeschaut und dachte mir so,
holla die Waldfee, also erstmal was für ein Umfang, aber wenn ich mir so die
ganzen Debatten, die wir jetzt auch hier in der Sendung zuletzt immer geführt
haben, nochmal so wachrufe, spielt da ja eine ganze Menge rein.
Also vielleicht mal einen Punkt rausgreifen, Breitbandversorgung,
Dauerlacher bei uns und hatten wir ja auch hier gerade wieder, aber einerseits,
Wissen wir, das ist etwas, das betrifft irgendwie das Land.
Der Trecker soll jetzt aber auch irgendwie autonom durch die Gegend fahren und
die Drohne drüber rumfliegen und mal gucken, wie das da mit der Dünnung eigentlich
so aussieht, was aber auch ein Umweltaspekt ist etc.
Also da fällt ja einiges zusammen.
Kann es sein, dass das jetzt sozusagen genauso das Ministerium ist,
wo man mal wieder was Neues ausprobieren kann, was wir so noch nicht hatten?
Genau das ist die Idee dahinter. Also das ist tatsächlich für mich auch wirklich
das beste Experimentierfeld, was ich jetzt so finden kann, weil Digitalisierung
in der Art, wie wir Netzpolitik bisher gemacht haben, das war alles schön und gut.
Das war wichtig, um die Gesellschaft nach vorne zu bringen und überhaupt erstmal
irgendwie auf den Stand der Technik und der Debatte zu bringen.
Aber was wir jetzt machen müssen, ist halt die anderen Bereiche,
in denen Digitalisierung jetzt ansteht und stattfindet, politisch damit zu verbinden.
Und das finde ich halt total spannend.
In einem Ministerium hast du da die Landwirte und die Digitalisierer und die
Leute, die eben Umwelt- und Energiewende machen, zusammensitzen und die müssen
gemeinsam darüber diskutieren, wie das dann eben läuft mit der Datenerhebung bei den Landwirten.
Wem gehören in Anführungszeichen die Daten dann?
Oder wie soll das laufen mit hier Smart Mieter in den Häusern und all so ein Kram.
Wie können wir die Digitalisierung der öffentlichen Verwaltung,
Stichwort Open Source, da gestalten?
Das ist ein super Experimentierfeld und das sind all die Themen,
die mich immer total bewegt haben.
Und das Spannende ist halt, da kann ich es wirklich machen. Und es ist eines
der ganz wenigen Ministerien in Deutschland, vielleicht sogar das einzige,
weiß ich nicht so genau, das eine eigene Abteilung für Digitalisierung mit vielen
Leuten hat und das eben koordiniert.
Also das ist schon so ein Pilotprojekt so ein bisschen.
Wir wünschen dir da viel Erfolg.
Danke auf jeden Fall.
Und danken dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast, heute noch hierher zu kommen.
Janne hat heute Morgen einen Podcast gemacht um 8 Uhr mit Sascha Lobo.
Heute Morgen 8 Uhr. Das war witzig. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sascha das erzählt hat.
Aber wir haben einen Podcast heute Morgen gemacht. Er meinte,
das Beste ist, wenn man kein Studio hat oder so, dann soll man sich in ein Auto setzen.
Haben wir uns in ein Auto gesetzt.
Er hat ja immer noch diesen blauen Audi. Nee, er hat wahrscheinlich inzwischen...
Warte, glaube ich, Karschek.
Und dann, Gott, ey.
Jetzt habe ich schon die ganzen Personenbezogene Daten über Sascha Lobo gelassen.
Dann werden wir das alles zurückzahlen.
Und dann hattet ihr heute ein zehnstündiges Event mit vielen Gästen und Themen
über Visionen für die digitale Politik.
Und jetzt entlassen wir dich und dein Team in die, ich glaube,
Abschluss- und Abschiedsfeier, weil du dich ja bald von deinem Team verabschiedest.
So ist es, wie man jetzt noch eine Abschiedsrunde.
Jetzt habt ihr die Gelegenheit, einmal Jan zu applaudieren und vor allem auch
Jans Team, was glaube ich da oben ist.
Da oben links.
Danke,
dass du da warst.
Vielen Dank.
Viel Erfolg in Schleswig-Holstein. Hat mich echt gefreut, danke.
So, boah, haben wir überzogen, wa?
Ja, wir haben richtig überzogen.
Aber wir machen trotzdem Pause, weil ihr braucht Luft und noch ein Getränk und
all die anderen Dinge. Und dann...
Wir machen wirklich um 22 Uhr weiter.
Ja.
Scharf, Punkt auf die Uhr, machen wir.
Also fix.
Die Yunus.
Musik,
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020,
Aber dann halt zieht und dann kommt der Schuss und so geht auch nicht.
Musik,
Ja, aber wir müssen jetzt loslegen.
So, sind wir schon auf dem Lenz? Nee, ne?
Wie heißt es so schön? Wer so sagt, hat noch lange nicht fertig.
So, wir müssen uns aber trotzdem ein bisschen sputen und gehen mal direkt zu
Gast Nummer drei, Gästin Nummer zwei.
Kannst du bitte einmal noch kurz die Situation da ein bisschen gastlicher herrichten.
Du meinst die Winkelkatze oder die leeren Fläschchen?
Die Winkel, das Winkelbierfläschchen. Und Wasser haben wir auch.
Die kann ja ruhig winken, die Katze.
Ja?
Ja, sicher. Aber ein frisches Glas können wir mal.
Da ist ein frisches Glas. So was ist schon gedacht. Das ist ein frisches Glas.
Das ist nur deshalb frisch, weil du allen anderen Gästen nichts zu trinken angeboten hast.
So geht das immer. Los.
Unsere nächste Gästin ist euch sicherlich auch bekannt.
Auch sie war bisher nicht im Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Aber wir haben häufig über sie und ihr Wirken gesprochen.
Auch bei unseren Freunden von der technischen Aufklärung habt ihr sie wahrscheinlich
regelmäßig gehört. und wir sind sehr froh, dass wir heute Martina Renner zu Gast haben.
Wer fängt an?
Du.
Okay, herzlich willkommen Martina Renner.
Hallo.
Du bist, ja, wir sind auf dich gekommen,
natürlich aufgrund deiner langjährigen Tätigkeit, lange lehre ich ja leider,
im NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss und der war ja bei uns schon sehr viel Thema und
ich glaube, es wäre auch zu viel verlangt, von dir jetzt zu erwarten,
dass du alles, was da geschehen ist,
vorträgst, Aber was uns persönlich wirklich interessiert, ist,
wie so dein Blick auf deine Erfahrungen in dieser Zeit sind.
Also ich glaube wirklich, hier ist der falsche Ort. Hier sind so viele Experten
und Expertinnen im Raum.
Jetzt nochmal nachzuerzählen, was wir festgestellt haben. Also,
dass es anloslose Massenüberwachung gab, dass es Spionage gab und ähnliches mehr.
Das wollen wir alles nicht sagen. Ich finde, wenn ich darüber reden würde,
was mich besonders auch im Nachgang politisch
beschäftigt, vielleicht auch persönlich, dann sind es zwei Dinge,
Zum einen, ich finde es einfach total krass, dass dort, wo Geheimdienste Rechtsverstöße
begehen und das tatsächlich bewusst, also nicht als Panne, sondern als System,
dort, wo sie Grundrechte brechen, es absolut folgenlos bleibt.
Wir haben doch die Situation im NSE-Untersuchungsausschuss gehabt,
dass wir sowohl im Abschlussbericht,
also insbesondere im Sondervotum der Opposition, als auch zum Beispiel in dem
Bericht der Datenschutzbeauftragten Frau Vosshoff, die ja nun nicht im Verdacht
steht, eine Linke zu sein.
Klar aufgelistet haben, so und
so viel Rechtsverstöße, so und so viel Beanstandungen und ähnliches mehr.
Niemand von denen, die dafür politisch Verantwortung getragen haben oder in
der Behörde dafür gesorgt haben,
dass zum Beispiel in das Grundrecht auf Kommunikationsfreiheit eingegriffen
wurden, dass es illegale Spionage gab, das ist in Deutschland auch,
ein Straftatbestand und ähnliches mehr, ist irgendwas passiert.
Das ist echt ein Punkt, den wir nochmal echt schärfer machen müssen.
Es gibt so etwas wie einen rechtsfreien Raum für Geheimdienste.
Und der heißt Internet. Also ist das Internet ein rechtsfreier Raum?
Nein, nein, und das ist jetzt genau der Punkt. Jetzt könnte man sagen,
ja, Weltraumtheorie war ja vorhin auch schon und so weiter.
Ja, klar, weil das ist irgendwie dieser Abgriff von Daten im Internet.
Der ist eben besonders regellos oder schwer zu regulieren und deswegen können
da die Geheimdienste außerhalb der Planke fahren.
Ich war ja vormals im NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss und da habe ich ja dasselbe festgestellt.
Auch dort sind Straftaten begangen worden. Dort sind Akten vernichtet worden.
Dort ist irgendwie Strafvereitelung begangen worden. Dort ist angestiftet worden.
Also insbesondere die Spitzel irgendwie, dass man Straftaten begehen soll und
so weiter. Das sind alles Straftatbestände. Auch dort ist derselbe Befund.
Dort, wo Geheimdienste Gesetze brechen,
Passiert mit denen gar nichts. Gar nichts.
Aber das stimmt doch nicht. Die haben doch danach alle mehr Geld bekommen.
Ja.
Das klingt jetzt so witzig, aber das ist ja Fakt.
Also der BND hat danach mehr Befugnisse bekommen, auch mehr Geld.
Also da war überhaupt kein irgendwie, ich bin schuldig, ich halte mich jetzt
mal ein bisschen zurück. Nee, gerade nochmal besonders irgendwie.
Auch in den Haushaltsverhandlungen die Hand aufgehalten.
Aber die neuen Befugnisse waren ja auch erforderlich, damit das,
was Sie vorher gemacht haben, nicht mehr illegal ist.
Genau, und Sie haben quasi das legalisiert, was Sie vorher als Gesetzesbruch
organisiert hatten. Das ist das Ähnliche wie beim NSU.
Danach haben Sie das Bundesverfassungsschutzgesetz geändert und haben danach
die Praxis der V-Mann-Führung so angepasst, dass man auch Schwerkriminelle führen kann.
Exakt dasselbe. Und auch die Person, das ist ja auch so ein Punkt.
Ich meine, da gehen dann die oben, also Fromm beim Verfassungsschutz und Schindler
beim BND und darunter, also die auch große Verantwortung tragen,
die Abteilungsleiter, die Referatsleiter,
die politische Ebene, die Staatssekretäre und so weiter, unsere Geheimdienstkoordinator,
da ist nichts.
Die werden zum Teil sogar noch befördert.
Denken wir an Herrn Kahl, der dieses Ganze eingespielt hat, auch in Bad Aibling
und jetzt Chef von CITES ist.
Und das müssen wir ändern. Wir müssen die Sanktionslosigkeit,
also die Rechtlosigkeit von Geheimdiensten ändern.
Warte mal, da kommt mir noch eine Frage. Warum passiert denn das?
Warum?
Ja.
Das ist jetzt eine gute Frage.
Die haben auch kluge, kluge Publikum.
Weil ich die auch nicht so eindeutig beantworten kann.
Also ist es so, dass es quasi ein über Jahrzehnte gewachsenes System gibt,
in dem klar ist, auch in der politischen Verantwortungsebene,
auch in den Strafverfolgungsbehörden und in der Justiz, dass man die Finger
lässt von Geheimdiensten.
Weil die Staatsanwaltschaften, also der Generalbundesanwalt hat ja ermittelt
in der Sache Merkel-Handy.
Da ist ja nichts passiert. Da ist ja nicht ein relevanter Ermittlungsschritt tatsächlich gewesen.
Ich glaube, die haben noch nicht mal sich das Ding angeguckt,
das Handy, geschweige denn, die könnten natürlich auch mal bei der NSA nachfragen
oder dort zum Beispiel natürlich auch Zeugen vorladen.
Die könnten auch Akten beiziehen und eben. Das haben die ja nicht gemacht.
Warum machen die das nicht? Entweder es gibt so eine Art Omerta,
also so ein Geschweigeding in den Behörden und in der Politik,
da wo Geheimdienste Dreck am Stecken haben, Gehen wir nicht rein, fassen wir nicht an.
Das wäre dann die andere Alternative. Es gibt da überhaupt kein Unrechtsbewusstsein
auf der politischen Ebene, also dass es keine bewusste politische Entscheidung
ist, sondern dass man das einfach so durchlaufen lässt.
Weil was ich nicht weiß, macht mich nicht heiß.
Die Rechts- und Fachaufsicht dann eher sagt, ich will das gar nicht so genau
wissen, was der BND macht. Nachher fragt mich noch jemand.
Das kann ich gar nicht entscheiden. Das eine wäre Vorsatz, das andere wäre,
Ja, können wir dann juristisch mal klären.
Aber der NS-Auer war ja jetzt erstmal nur rein parlamentarisch organisiert.
Wie hast du denn dann da die anderen wahrgenommen?
Das stimmt ja nicht so, dass es nur ein parlamentarisches Gremium ist.
Zum einen sitzt die Strafverfolgungsbehörde, die oberste in Deutschland,
also der Generalbundesanwalt mit seiner Vertreterin, seinem Vertreter immer
in den Sitzungen und hätte die Gelegenheit jederzeit Erkenntnisse aus dem Untersuchungsausschuss
auch in die Strafverfolgung einzubinden.
Und zum anderen ist ja das, worüber wir dort Beweis erhoben haben,
auch durch die Blogs, durch die vielen Presseartikel, durch die Protokolle, die da erstanden sind,
ja auch außerhalb des Parlaments so weit bekannt gewesen, dass jederzeit auch
eine Staatsanwaltschaft hätte sagen können, krasse Sache irgendwie,
was da passiert irgendwie,
da müssen wir mal hinterher irgendwie, wenn die NSA in Berlin irgendwie die
Behördentelefone abhört.
Ja, das ist ja nicht jetzt erst ein Problem irgendwie, dass das Behördennetz
anfällig ist und so weiter.
Machen die halt nicht. Also die interessiert das halt nicht.
Also entweder laissez-faire oder Kompromat. Ich weiß gar nicht,
was mich jetzt mehr beunruhigen soll.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mich mehr beunruhigen sollte, aber ich glaube, das ist eine Frage,
die wir in Zukunft im Zusammenhang mit der Frage, funktioniert Kontrolle von
Geheimdiensten oder funktioniert sie per se gar nicht, weil Geheimdienste sich
nicht kontrollieren lassen, stärker in den Fokus rücken müssen.
Die Frage, inwieweit wir überhaupt irgendeine Form der Möglichkeit haben,
dass auch rechtsstaatlich das, was dort falsch läuft im Nachgang,
bestraft wird. Dass die einfach mal den Gong hören.
Die haben den nicht gehört. Die sind da rausgegangen, haben gesagt, hat funktioniert.
Ich habe dreimal gesagt, kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Habe schön die Akten
geschwärzt irgendwie, habe das Parlament angelogen.
Da wären wir beim zweiten persönlichen Befund, was mich wahnsinnig ärgert.
Die Unverfrorenheit, wie dort gegenüber dem Parlament agiert wird und wie viele
Abgeordnete sich das bieten lassen.
Die haben so viele Anfragen falsch beantwortet.
Die haben so offen dort, wenn sie im Zeugenstand saßen, uns angeschissen. Beispiel.
Beispiel zum Beispiel, es ging ja dann um diese NSA-Selektoren,
also diese Suchbegriffe,
die illegal waren, weil sie sich auf Regierungsziele gerichtet haben oder auf
NGOs oder auf Presse und ähnliches.
Und da haben die uns erzählt, dass es nur auf ganz unterster Ebene in einer
Außenstelle mal ein bisschen so aufgefallen, aber oben haben die davon gar nichts gewusst.
Das glaubt halt niemand, der eine hierarchische Behörde kennt und weiß,
wie das da läuft irgendwie.
Wenn solche Operationen laufen mit so einer Relevanz und wir reden um Millionen
von Suchbegriffen, dann weiß natürlich auch die Behördenspitze Bescheid.
Und die haben bis zum Schluss einen durchgelogen und haben gesagt,
sie wussten davon nichts.
Und das ist so ein Punkt, wo ich sage, das glaube ich nicht.
Da weiß man auch schon wieder nicht, was einen mehr aufregen soll,
dass sie es nicht wissen oder es nicht zugegeben.
Also das Schlimme ist ja irgendwie, dass dann auch eben so viele Abgeordnete
total arschlos sind, weil so ein Untersuchungsausschuss
hat ja total viele Kompetenzen auch, die er nie zieht.
Er könnte auch, wenn dort zum Beispiel Zeugen in Widerspruch geraten oder wenn man das Gefühl hat,
irgendwie nach meinem Aktenlesen und dem, was er jetzt sagt,
kann das nicht stimmen, der lügt und so weiter, könnte man ja bestimmte Sachen machen.
Man könnte zum Beispiel die beiden, die im Widerspruch standen,
irgendwie zusammen vernehmen.
Das wird für die dann unangenehm, weil einer von den beiden muss dann aus der Nummer irgendwie raus.
Man könnte aber auch Leuten tatsächlich Ordnungsgeld androhen und Ähnliches für Lügen und so was.
Man könnte die vereidigen und so was. Das wird halt nie gemacht,
weil da sitzen wie viele Abgeordnete, die nur ein wichtiges Ziel verfolgen,
irgendwie irgendein schlechtes Buch zu schreiben, irgendwie unser Ausschussvorsitzender.
Und ansonsten irgendwie sich als Schutzschild irgendwie vor die Geheimdienste
zu werfen, vermutlich, weil sie nicht nur das als Parteien- Fraktionsauftrag
verstehen, sondern wirklich an das System glauben, möglicherweise sogar persönliche
Verbindungen dahin haben.
Ich meine, wie viele davon Gediente waren und Reservisten, die haben ja fast
immer salutiert, wenn dann die Generäle vor uns saßen.
Welche Rolle hat denn die sogenannte vierte Gewalt in dem ganzen Spiel gespielt? War das...
Also ohne das funktioniert es nicht.
Also ich meine die Presse.
Ja, ich weiß es. Deswegen sage ich, welche Rolle, die war tippt.
Diese Klug, ja, es stimmt.
Die Klug. Technische Aufklärung mit der Block von Netzpolitik irgendwie, das war doch irgendwie.
Also wenn die Arbeit eines Untersuchungsausschusses nicht begleitet wird durch
Öffentlichkeit, durch Engagierte, durch Presse, aber vor allem unabhängige Presse,
dann ist es da vollkommen egal, was wir da stundenlang treiben.
Das ist die Stärke eines Untersuchungsausschusses, wenn er es schafft,
seine Informationen über Bande zu spielen.
Das ist die Stärke gewesen im NSU-Aufklärungskontest, wenn wir zum Beispiel an NSU-Watch denken.
Und das war die Stärke im NSE-Untersuchungsausschuss, wenn wir an die ganze
Arbeit denken, die auf der Tribüne über uns gemacht wurde.
Oder noch nachts um ein Uhr saßen wir zusammen und haben hier podcasttechnische
Aufklärung gemacht. Genau.
Und jetzt kommt noch etwas dazu und die sind auch nochmal deswegen wichtig,
weil wir ja unter diesem ganzen Geheimhaltungsregime, die sehr permanente Androhung,
wenn ihr was aus geheimen Akten erzählt,
dann ziehen wir euch vor Gericht und buchten euch ein und ähnliches mehr.
Bei euch geht das dann auf einmal?
Ne, also ich sage mal, Abgeordnete lassen sich schon auch durch sowas beeindrucken.
Man weiß ja nie so genau, ich meine, so ein Dr.
Maaßen, der hat auch schon so eine Bösartigkeit, dem traut man auch echt was zu, oder?
Also mir kommt der so vor, also es ist schon das Evil aus Köln-Korweiler, ne?
Und und wenn man dann sieht, irgendwie, okay, irgendwie,
Es gibt dann doch immer wieder Informationen, die den Licht der Öffentlichkeit
finden und zum Beispiel dieser Bericht der Datenschutzbeauftragten und so weiter,
dann ist das natürlich auch super, weil es uns die Möglichkeit gibt,
dann doch auch im Rahmen der Beweisaufnahme im Abschlussbericht und so weiter
über diese Dinge zu sprechen, die total wichtig sind und die nicht geheimhaltungsbedürftig sind.
Sondern maximal nur peinlich für die Bundesregierung waren.
Und deswegen, das hat super geklappt und ich hoffe oder wünsche mir,
dass insbesondere auch diese Zusammenarbeit auch in den weiteren Auseinandersetzungen
trägt, weil wir stehen ja jetzt, wenn wir uns die Sicherheitsgesetzgebung anschauen und so weiter,
denke ich vor vielen Fragen, wo wir große Öffentlichkeit zu brauchen,
weit über Bayern hinaus.
Also die Debatte dort um das Polizeiaufgabengesetz, die holt uns in vielen anderen
Bundesländern jetzt auch.
Die wird uns in veränderter Form auch im Bund begegnen und vieles mehr und da
brauchen wir auch diese Netzwerke, die sich da aufgebaut haben, auch weiterhin.
Ja, da möchte der Heimathorst auch nochmal ordentlich punkten,
wahrscheinlich. Als ich das mit der vierten Gewalt, also mit der Presse meinte,
war jetzt gar nicht so Fishing for Compliments für so diese alternative Medienberichterstattung,
die war sicherlich außergewöhnlich.
Ich frage mich bloß immer nur, fühlt man sich sozusagen mit so einer Innenansicht
dann auch in der definierenden Presse, sag ich mal, also die,
die sozusagen auch von einem Großteil der Bevölkerung akzeptiert wird,
korrekt vertreten und wenn ja, warum wirkt das dann nicht in die Gesellschaft rein?
Weil, wenn wir uns die großen Medien anschauen, die über den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss
berichtet haben, wir schon häufig das Gefühl hatten, die haben so ein krasses,
rasches Themenhopping gemacht.
Die fanden dann irgendwas mal interessant, irgendein Dokument interessant,
irgendeine Software oder ein Tool interessant, dann haben die drüber geschrieben
und dann haben die das aber nicht langfristig verfolgt, Also keine wirklich
auch investigative Recherche gemacht,
sondern irgendwie Befund genommen, drüber geschrieben und eben das auch nicht wirklich analysiert.
Und da fehlt eben oftmals in den großen Portalen, insbesondere dort,
wo sie online arbeiten, die Leute, die Bock haben, sich mit einer langen Strecke zu beschäftigen.
Wir hatten so Stücke auch, zum Beispiel Exkisekommel im Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz
bei Zeit Online von Kai Biermann.
Das ist so ein Gegenbeispiel, wo wirklich mal versucht wurde,
das zu durchdringen und lange zu erzählen.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, das machen viele halt nicht.
Und du musst bei solchen Komplexen wie dieser BND-NSE-Zusammenarbeit,
musst du versuchen, nicht nur die Details zu schildern, sondern das System dahinter.
Das ist wie beim NSU ähnlich. Da hilft es mir nicht, den 41.
Spitzel in der Naziszene zu erzählen, sondern du musst das System erzählen, das kriminelle System.
Und da fehlen manchmal in den großen Medien das Interesse oder die Leute.
Das heißt Fazit, viel Arbeit, man merkt, das war ja auch nicht scheißegal.
Und am Ende das Einzige, was du jetzt Positives daraus ziehen kannst,
weil der Ausschuss selber nicht eine direkte Wirkung entfaltet hat,
ist die indirekte Wirkung, dass darüber gesprochen wurde, dass es in Medien aufgegriffen wurde.
Also ich glaube, es gibt tatsächlich positive Wirkungen.
Also niemand würde mehr heute beschreiten, dass es anlasslose Massenüberwachung,
insbesondere im Bereich der Internetkommunikation, durch die Geheimdienste gibt.
Und wie das auch technisch organisiert ist, haben wir mittlerweile ein relativ
gutes Gefühl dazu, ein bisschen was verstanden zu haben.
Das ermöglicht uns ja auch Gegenstrategien, insbesondere des digitalen Selbstschutzes,
dann auch zu entwickeln.
Und das andere ist, glaube ich, ich finde jeden Baustein interessant,
wo wir das System, finde ich, der demokratiefeindlichen Geheimdienste delegitimieren.
Das heißt, das ist so eine Arbeit
auf lange Strecke. Das ist wie die Auseinandersetzung um die Atomenergie.
Da haben wir Jahrzehnte gebraucht. Am Anfang hieß es irgendwie,
wenn wir die Kernkraftwerke abschalten, irgendwie geht das Licht aus.
Und bis dann eine Meinung in der Bevölkerung sich so weit geändert hatte,
da kamen natürlich die großen Katastrophen dazu.
Aber dass eine Mehrheit sagte, ich will das nicht mehr, ich will raus aus dieser
gefährlichen Hochsicherheitstechnologie,
glaube ich, die Auseinandersetzung mit Geheimdiensten müssen wir auch auf lange
Strecke sehen, dass irgendwann auch Mehrheiten gesellschaftlich dafür da sind
zu sagen, wir wollen solche Behörden mit solchen Befugnissen,
die sich nicht kontrollieren lassen wollen, nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Also man muss dazu sagen, Martina Renner ist seit wie vielen Jahren Sprecherin für Antifaschistische.
Politik in der zweiten Legislatur jetzt. Das ist mein eigentlicher Sprecherinnenposten,
das andere ist immer nur so eine Dreingabe, dass ich die Untersuchungsausschüsse
mache und war vormals aber auch biografisch mit diesem Thema anders verbunden,
außerparlamentarisch, also ich komme aus der Antifa.
Das kann man auch sagen und viele sind ja da ein bisschen verschämt bei sowas.
Klar, das ist für mich, die ich das noch nicht erlebt habe im Parlament,
erst mal schon so, dass man da hinguckt und hinhört.
Weil am Anfang fand ich auch in der Berichterstattung, da lief das eben so unter dem Motto,
na ja, das wird sich im Parlament alles ein bisschen mäßigen,
die werden da nicht die harten NS-Sprechsachen anschlagen, irgendwie,
die werden entzaubert und ähnliches mehr und da darf nicht so viel Energie drauf
verschwendet werden, irgendwie auch,
ganz klar zu benennen, welche sowohl Ideologie dort vertreten wird,
also in den Reden, in den Anträgen und so weiter, als auch sich mit den Personen zu beschäftigen,
also wer kommt da aus welcher neonazistischen Organisation, das spielt ja insbesondere
für die Mitarbeiter und Mitarbeiterinnen-Ebene eine große Rolle,
die kommen ja aus Kameradschaftsszenen anderen neonazistischen Parteien wie die Rechte, aber auch,
verbotenen Organisationen wie der Heimatrollen Deutschen Jugend.
Und wenn man dann aber plötzlich diese Akteure da hat, diese Reden hört,
und da sind ja einige dabei, die wirklich,
so blitzsauber irgendwie nationalsozialistischen Jargon ablassen, wie der Curio,
also der im Bereich Innenpolitik Das ist der, der auch immer versucht,
Goebbels gestik und Mimik nachzumachen.
Dann merkt man halt schon relativ deutlich, das ist im Kern eine faschistische Organisation,
die darauf zielt, nicht nur das Parlament, die Demokratie zu beseitigen,
den Rechtsstaat, sondern wenn sie könnten,
auch noch mehr als sie es bisher auch schon getan haben, ihren außerparlamentarischen
Arm von Begida bis militanten Nazis und Rassisten auf Leute losschicken.
Dieses Gefühl, die sitzen jetzt da und das sind die, die in ihren Chats schreiben,
alle an die Wand stellen, irgendwie in die Grube und Löschkalk drauf.
Das war der Fraktionsvorsitzende der AfD in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Und das sind die, die auch das denken und das wollen und das als politisches Ziel haben.
Das macht schon was mit einem. Das geht nicht an einem vorbei,
das geht auch nicht an den Leuten vorbei, die im Parlament arbeiten.
Man guckt jetzt schon irgendwie, wer über den Flur schleicht irgendwie und so.
Das heißt aber auch, die Auseinandersetzung ist da, die wird angenommen und
die wird geführt und wir müssen die auch gewinnen.
Also wir haben auch ein Ziel, ja, also wir müssen auch irgendwie die AfD wieder klein machen.
Und wer ist wir jetzt?
Mir ist für mich immer keine Frage jetzt nur, dass es stabile Bündnisse im Parlament
geben muss, unter den Demokraten und Demokratinnen.
Das wünsche ich mir natürlich, aber ich sehe da im Augenblick auch Sollbruchstellen.
Es hat ganz gut funktioniert irgendwie, also bei den Personalvorschlägen zum
Beispiel zum Amt des Klaser, also zum Vizepräsidenten des Bundestages,
dass der abgelehnt wurde und so weiter,
weil da Skandalisierung ihrer Personalvorschläge für andere Ausschüsse und dass
Anträge von denen grundsätzlich durchfallen und dass auch klare Reden gehalten werden.
Ich sehe nur, wir sind noch in dieser Anfangszeit.
Was wird, wenn das weiterläuft? Und wenn ich in die Landtage schaue,
wo die AfD schon länger sitzt, da ist ja mittlerweile die Tabu-Grenze schon gebrochen.
Also da macht man zusammen zum Beispiel in Sachsen-Anhalt diese Enquete-Kommission
Linksextremismus fröhlich irgendwie von der CDU irgendwie mit der AfD.
Und ähnliches mehr, also wo man diese zivilgesellschaftlichen Projekte irgendwie
angreifen will, irgendwie dort gegen Rechtsarbeiten oder Opfer von rechter und
rassistischer Gewalt schützen.
Und ob diese Grenze...
Das hat aber die CDU auch schon vorher gemacht.
Ja, genau, aber da läuft die Zusammenarbeit schon sehr viel harmonischer.
Und da kann man sich ja auch schon vorstellen, da gibt es ja schon Gedankenspiele
in Brandenburg und Sachsen, dass man vielleicht auch zusammen in die Regierung könnte und so.
Und ich glaube, auf Dauer wird es im Bundestag immer mehr Stimmen geben,
insbesondere aus FDP und CSU,
die eben auch punktuelle Zusammenarbeit mit der AfD suchen werden und die Auseinandersetzung
und diesen Untersuchungsausschuss zum Bundesamt für Migration und Flucht wird
da einer der Hauptpunkte nächster Zeit werden,
ob die, also ich meine die Haltung der Demokratinnen und Demokraten gegenüber der AfD klar ist.
Aber es gibt schon noch ein Wir, was auch ein bisschen funktioniert?
Ja, ja, also wir, also das ist, also wir jetzt zum Beispiel zuletzt,
Wir hatten eine Auseinandersetzung auch im Breitscheidplatz-Untersuchungsausschuss,
weil der AfD-Abgeordnete da krasseste diskriminierenden Sprech abgelassen hat,
den ich hier nicht wiederhole irgendwie,
aber das funktioniert.
Also bisher funktioniert das überwiegend, aber ich habe ein bisschen Sorge,
dass es auch noch in einem Jahr funktioniert.
Du hast jetzt schon deinen nächsten Untersuchungsausschuss genannt.
Du stehst ja schon irgendwie so auf diese Untersuchungsausschüsse,
wobei das ja wirklich eine sehr frustrierende Arbeit zu sein scheint.
Jetzt Untersuchungsausschuss, Breitscheidplatz, worum geht es?
Naja, der Anlass ist klar. Es gab diesen Anschlag eines Dschihadisten mit zwölf
Toten und es gibt viele Fragen.
Es gibt insbesondere Fragen natürlich der Angehörigen und der Überlebenden.
Hätte der Anschlag verhindert werden können, wenn Behörden im Vorfeld die richtigen
Maßnahmen ergriffen haben? Das ist tatsächlich so eine Kernfrage,
die uns ja auch immer im NSU-Komplex umgetrieben hat.
Und wenn ich da reingehe, trägt mich erst mal immer diese Frage auch der Betroffenen als erstes.
Weil wir haben halt gemügend Anhaltspunkte zu denken,
dass die Behörden wahrscheinlich im Vorfeld mehr wussten zu den Tatvorbereitungen, zu den Absichten,
zu der Vernetzung auch der Person in ein dschihadistisches Netzwerk,
als sie dann zugegeben haben.
Und das müssen wir natürlich aufklären.
Das ist ein bisschen tatsächlich so, wenn wir mal überlegen,
wir hatten beim NSU diese These der Medien und der Behörden, das ist ein Trio.
Zwei sind tot, das ist immer super, eine ist noch da, die hat dann noch so ein
paar Helfer, aber die kommen nach München, werden abgeurteilt und fertig ist
der Lack, niemand redet mehr über das Netzwerk.
Und wir wissen gleichzeitig, die militante Struktur, die die ganze Unterstützungsleistung
organisiert hat, Das war platt in anderen, europaweites, agierendes,
extrem narzisstisches, bewaffnetes, paramilitärisch organisiertes Nazi-Netzwerk.
Ist doch logisch, die Dienste, die Behörden hatten dieses Netzwerk komplett
irgendwie durchsetzt, infiltriert.
Die haben sogar den Kopf dieses Netzwerkes, also den Divisionschef in Deutschland als Spitzel geführt.
Und wenn wir das als Analogie nehmen, zu wem hatte Anis Amri,
der Attentäter, Kontakt?
Ja das ist irgendwie das Netzwerk um abowalla aber wala ist quasi der es,
zuständige für deutschland ja der war eingebunden in ein netzwerk da gab es
informationen zu ihm und zu anderen da sind spitzel auf ihn angesetzt worden
oder hat selbst in über ihnen informationen weitergegeben und die frage ist,
Wenn man das nicht ernst genommen hat, hat man einen krassen Fehler gemacht.
Wenn man das alles wusste, der will sich einen LKW besorgen,
der ist bereit, der macht ein Video, was er dann als Bekenntnis in die Welt
schicken will und so weiter und hat das laufen lassen, hat man sich schuldig gemacht.
Und das muss geklärt werden, auch für die Zukunft, weil es geht ja auch immer
um die Frage, was ist denn das richtige Mittel, mit dem die Behörden auf solche
Entwicklungen reagieren, auf dschihadistischen Terror in Europa zum Beispiel.
Und da kommen halt die Konservativen und sagen, klar kennen wir alles,
wir wollen jetzt Gesichtserkennung, Videokameras und wir wollen Fußfessel und
all diesen Tünnes. Und wir sagen, das funktioniert halt nicht.
Kein Videokamera hätte den gestoppt. Sondern da müssen ganz andere Entscheidungen
laufen, dass Informationen richtig bewertet werden. Da brauche ich nicht tausend
Videokameras in Berlin.
Und darüber geht so eine Auseinandersetzung dann auch, dass man natürlich immer versucht,
dass das Ansinnen der Sicherheitsfanatiker über solche Untersuchungsausschüsse
quasi an der sicherheitspolitischen Schraube zu drehen,
unterlaufen werden, indem man ihnen nachweist, das, was ihr vorschlagt,
ist gar nicht ein effektives Mittel, um das, was wir tatsächlich dort erlebt
haben, an Radikalisierung, an Tatvorbereitung, an Netzwerkstrukturen zu bekämpfen.
Das ist eine Debatte, wo diese Untersuchungsausschüsse auch wirklich Sinn machen,
weil wir tatsächlich auch im Baustein sind,
in einer wirklich intensiven Auseinandersetzung, den Rest von Bürger,
Menschen und Grundrechten in der Sicherheitsgesetzgebung in diesem Land weiterhin zu behalten.
Aber ist es immer so ein Verhindern oder kann man irgendwie auch,
also ist es immer ein Verhindern von Rückschritten oder Eindämmen von Rückschritten
oder gibt es auch Fortschritte?
Also kommt aus der Arbeit, also jetzt vielleicht nicht nur in den Untersuchungsausschüssen,
auch irgendwas bei raus, wo man vielleicht auch so eine halbwegs optimistische
Perspektive entwickeln kann mit, da tut sich auch was?
Ja, also ich glaube, es gibt eine Perspektive, die es aber nicht auf das Parlament beschränkt.
Die Auseinandersetzung in diesen Ausschüssen, das kann ich für den NSU-Ausschuss
wie den NSE-Ausschuss sagen,
hat dazu geführt, dass Menschen, die bis dato politisch nicht zusammengearbeitet
haben, weil ihre Communities ziemlich weit voneinander getrennt sind,
also zum Beispiel bei NSU die migrantische Community und die Antifa,
ich würde jetzt sagen beim NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss die netzpolitische Community
und Leute wie ich, die eher so irgendwie auseinandersetzen mit Geheimdiensten
fahren und so weiter, plötzlich gemerkt haben, sie haben Berührungspunkte,
sie haben auch gemeinsame Vorstellungen von Verteidigung von Freiheitsrechten
und so weiter und ich glaube,
da haben die Untersuchungsausschüsse auch tatsächlich eine Chance,
irgendwie teilweise unsere sehr politisch getrennten Sphären,
die alle für sich gut funktionieren, aber meistens so als Bubble,
irgendwie mal zusammenzubringen und mal zu verstehen irgendwie,
dass wir viele gemeinsame Vorstellungen haben, wie eine freiheitliche demokratische
Gesellschaft anders aussehen könnte.
Nicht, dass mir jetzt nicht noch tausend Fragen einfallen würden.
Zum Beispiel die Frage, wie wir irgendwie hier um 11 Uhr rauskommen wollen.
Das ist mir auch noch ein Geze.
Wir wünschen dir auf jeden Fall viel Erfolg und Kraft bei dieser Arbeit,
die ich ehrlich gesagt so frustrierend finden würde.
Ich sage jetzt sowas, das machst du ja nicht alleine.
Hier sitzt eine Mitarbeiterin im NSE-Untersuchung, hier sitzt Matthias,
der Mitarbeiter jetzt für den Breitscheidplatz-Untersuchungsausschuss.
Wir tragen das auch weg, weil wir das auf viele Schultern verteilen und weil
wir auch wissen, dass es Interesse gibt.
Wenn wir merken würden, es gibt kein Interesse mehr für die Auseinandersetzung,
würde das keinen Sinn machen. Das ist überhaupt bei Politik so.
Wir machen das nicht für uns.
Und deswegen, auch wenn es erstmal jetzt ganz anders klingt,
guckt mal, was in diesem neuen Untersuchungsausschuss passiert.
Ich glaube, da wird es viele Déjà-vus geben und das wird an vielen grundsätzlichen Fragen auch rühren.
Gibt es schon einen Podcast dafür?
Nein, gibt es noch nicht. Insgesamt ist die Pressebeobachtung und die Öffentlichkeit
nicht so doll, aber wir hoffen, in dem Moment, wo wir mit der Zeugeneinvernahme
beginnen, wird es ein bisschen anders sich drehen.
Okay, also wer noch ein Podcast-Projekt sucht, Weitscheidplatz.
Martina, vielen, vielen Dank. Danke.
Und für die Arbeit.
Und Applaus auch für Anne und Matthias, wie ihr Publikum sich befindet.
Genau.
Oh, Vorsicht.
Da geht es.
Da wurden wir vorgewarnt, da runter zu gehen.
So, wir haben maßlos überzogen, wir wissen das. Deswegen schreiten wir fleißig
voran und holen unseren vierten und letzten Gast,
für den auf jeden Fall auch last but not least gilt, nämlich Arne Semsrott.
Hallo Arne.
Moin.
Könnt ihr noch?
Kannst du noch? Wir haben dich ja fest bis 18 Uhr hierhin bestellt.
Ich werde immer wacher. Ich könnte jetzt hier noch stundenlang weitermachen,
aber da haben wir irgendwie nicht das richtige Mietkonzept.
Stört euch das, wenn nachher im Hintergrund ein Stummfilm läuft?
Machen wir nicht. So gut war der noch nie besucht.
Kleiner Hinweis, wenn mir das bei Martina so auffiel, für die Leute,
die das jetzt hier als Podcast hören und ihr habt manchmal das Gefühl,
es wird an den falschen Stellen gelacht.
Es gibt da so ein Video, das läuft hier hinter uns, da wird fleißig gemalt und
ich habe so den Eindruck, manchmal gibt es so eine leichte Dissonanz zwischen
dem Thema und so, weil die karikaturistische Anspielung so schön war.
So, Arne, kommen wir jetzt mal zu dir.
Du bist jetzt ein bisschen mehr wieder der Vertreter des Aktivismus,
würde ich mal sagen. Kommst du damit klar mit der Bezeichnung? Oder stehst du dich so?
Vor kurzem gab es so einen Spiegelartikel und da wurde ich so genannt und dann
hat meine Mutter mich angerufen und meinte,
können die nicht wenigstens Politikwissenschaftler schreiben oder so?
Aber mein Vater meinte dann, nö, nö, ist doch okay, ist doch angesehen,
ist doch, kann man machen. Ja, ist gut.
Ja, ja, Spiegel hat mich auch mal Medienkünstler genannt. Das kann man alles übergeben.
Ja, also wie bist du denn abgerutscht? Wie bist du denn in diesen Aktivismus abgerutscht?
Bist du im Aktivismus abgeglitten?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Es kam irgendwie so relativ von Anfang an,
Ich habe angefangen hier in Berlin vor zehn Jahren oder acht oder so mit einem
Politikwissenschaftsstudium und ich wusste gleich, das ist nichts für mich.
Und bin dann durch verschiedene NGOs, durch irgendwie Organisationen getingelt
und habe mich im Journalismus versucht und das wurde alles nichts.
War dann bei Transparency International, habe da so ein Projekt gemacht,
Hochschulwatch heißt das, zu Verbindung von Hochschulen und Wirtschaft.
Und da kam ich dann allmählich schon so in Richtung Informationsfreiheit und
bin dann darüber relativ schnell zu Frag den Staat gekommen.
Und das mache ich jetzt seit einigen Jahren und darüber ergeben sich viele andere schöne Projekte.
Jetzt können Sie hier praktisch starten von Stefan Wehrmeier mal losgetreten
worden. Du bist dann sozusagen dazu gestoßen. Wie viele Leute machen da noch mit?
Wir sind zu dritt im Kernteam, Nadine Stamm, Stefan Wehrmeier und ich, auf 1,3 Stellen.
Insgesamt.
Genau, ja, zusammen.
Nicht pro Kopf.
Und dann aber ein größeres Team und wenn wir groß wirken sollen,
dann nehme ich halt alle Leute, die mal eine Anfrage gestellt haben dazu.
Das heißt, wir sind so ein Team von knapp 10.000 Leuten.
Auf 1,3 Stellen.
Wie lange läuft das jetzt schon?
Seit 2011 läuft das.
Und läuft gut, oder?
Läuft immer besser. 1,3 Stellen sind auch die meisten Stellen,
die wir ehemals dafür hatten.
Und wir sind gut wahrgenommen, also wahrscheinlich noch mehr in der Behördenwelt
als in der generellen Bevölkerung so und haben, glaube ich, darüber schon relativ
viele Einflussmöglichkeiten.
Allein dadurch, dass wir die Plattform haben, über die man Anfragen stellen
kann an die Behörden, über die mehr als die Hälfte aller Anfragen überhaupt
in Deutschland an die Behörden gehen, darüber können wir so eine Art Standard setzen schon mal.
Und das ist so eine ganz interessante Position, in der wir da sind.
Ja, die auch jedes Jahr wieder mit neuen Highlights irgendwie gefüllt wird.
Du kennst ja unsere Gespräche immer, wenn es um den Kongress geht und dann so,
ja, soll ich eigentlich nochmal was einreichen?
Ja, nee, wir wollen ja eigentlich dich nicht schon wieder da haben,
aber wenn du jetzt da eingereicht hast, ist ja doch schon wieder leider geil.
Ich weiß nicht, seit wie vielen Jahren du jetzt in Folge zusammen mit Stefan
auf den CCC-Kongressbühnen bist.
Und jedes Jahr hast du irgendwie mehrere neue coole Storys mit,
wie ihr als Schreibtisch-Hooligans immer wieder neue Datenberge befreit.
Was sind so deine Highlights der Anfragen?
Vielleicht auch gar nicht die wirkmächtigsten, sondern die amüsantesten.
Also für den 35C3 habe ich ein richtig gutes GIF jetzt gemacht.
Das klären wir ein anderes mal.
Das ist ein richtig gutes GIF.
Okay, vielleicht machen wir es von Ernst bis fröhlich und ich fange erstmal mit Ernst an.
Wir haben vor ein paar Wochen ein Dokument vom Auswärtigen Amt veröffentlicht.
Das war ein interner Drahtbericht, also was von der Botschaft nach Deutschland
geschickt wurde, über Flüchtlingslager in Libyen, also sogenannte Privatgefängnisse.
So steht es in diesem Drahtbericht drin, wo beschrieben wird,
wie die Verhältnisse sind.
Da wird dann zum Beispiel beschrieben, dass Flüchtlinge täglich misshandelt
werden, dass es Handyvideos davon gibt,
dass jede Woche fünf Leute aus dem Flüchtlingslager exekutiert werden auf dem
Hauptplatz, um Platz zu schaffen für neue Leute.
So, und dann steht da dieses ganze Dokument, das sind ein paar Seiten und am
Ende des Dokuments steht dann, ja, und deswegen müssen wir mehr Leute davon
abbringen, nach Europa zu kommen, damit die nicht in diesen Flüchtlingslagern enden oder so.
Das ist ein Dokument, da haben wir über ein halbes Jahr versucht,
das zu kriegen, haben es erstmal angefragt.
Dann wurde uns erstmal gesagt, nee, das gibt es nicht. Dann haben wir es nochmal
angefragt und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, okay, es gibt es doch, aber kriegst du nicht.
Mit der Ablehnung, die internationalen Beziehungen werden gefährdet.
Wenn Libyen rausfindet, was wir über Libyen schreiben, sind unsere internationalen
Beziehungen mit Libyen gefährdet.
Dann habe ich Widerspruch dagegen eingelegt, dass internationale Beziehungen
nur zu richtigen Staaten sind und nicht zu Failed States.
Und dann haben sie mir das ganze Ding so halb geschwärzt nur zugeschickt.
Und was spannend ist an diesem Dokument, finde ich, ist, dass das nicht wahnsinnig neu ist.
Das sind alles nicht unbedingt Infos, die an sich jetzt komplett,
also man hat davon irgendwie schon gehört, aber es ist schwarz auf weiß da und
es ist das Logo vom Auswärtigen Amt drauf und es ist so klar,
alle wissen davon und man kann es nicht mehr leugnen, es ist nämlich das Dokument
und es ist nicht irgendwo zitiert, sondern es ist wirklich das Ding da und das,
finde ich, zeigt so sehr gut die Kraft, die dahinter ist,
Originaldokumente zu kriegen und tatsächlich die Kopien aus den Aktenbergen
zu haben und dann die Geschichte damit verbinden zu können.
Und dann haben wir eine super Anfrage nach Abiturklausuren. Ist das ein blöder Übergang?
Wir können ja alles ab.
Es ist tatsächlich so alles von ernst bis in sowas.
Die am besten gehende Anfrage, die die meiste Medienberichterstattung weltweit
hatte, war eine Anfrage von einem 17-jährigen Schüler aus NRW,
der vor dem Abitur seine Abiturklausuren haben wollte.
Der hat sich das EWG angeschaut, hat gesehen, ja, es gibt keinen Ablehnungsgrund
für Prüfungsunterlagen. Die sind jetzt schon fertig, ich kann die kriegen.
Und das ist dann schnell so in die internationale Presse gegangen und dann die
Briten so, ah ja, die Deutschen, die fragen erst mal um Erlaubnis,
bevor sie irgendwie cheaten.
Aber es gibt am Ende einen Stimpel.
Und dann hatte das Schulamt in Nordrhein-Westfalen tatsächlich ein Problem,
die mussten sich dann so einen Ablehnungsgrund irgendwie zusammenzimmern, es gibt so Schutz,
des behördlichen Entscheidungsprozesses und dann haben die gesagt,
ja eine Prüfung ist ja wieder Entscheidungsprozess von der Behörde,
deswegen wird es abgelehnt und dann hat er es nicht bekommen,
aber einen Tag nach dem Abi hat er es dann direkt zugeschickt bekommen,
hat ihm nicht mehr viel genutzt, aber für die nächsten.
Der Versuch zählt.
Und daran sehen wir jedes Jahr wieder, wenn Abi-Zeit ist, immer wieder,
wenn ein paar hundert Anfragen überfragt in den Staat nach Abi-Klosion gehen,
dann wissen wir, ah ja, sind wieder Leute in der Vorprüfungsphase gerade.
Aber hat ja auch, also abgesehen von dem humoristischen Aspekt,
ist das natürlich auch so ein Element, was den Leuten dieses Werkzeug ja auch näher bringt.
Genau und das ist halt wirklich nicht einfach, weil es an sich ja wahnsinnig langweilig ist.
Also es geht um Akten. Was gibt es langweiligeres als Akten?
Und wir müssen halt immer versuchen, das irgendwie so aufzubereiten,
dass man versteht, was dahinter ist und das versuchen wir halt relativ viel
dann mit Kampagnen zu machen.
Also mit im Prinzip vorgefertigten Anfragen, die wir Leuten vorbereiten,
die sie dann anklicken können.
So ein Beispiel dafür ist Frag den Bundestag, das haben wir vor zwei Jahren gemacht.
Da ging es um die Gutenberg-Gutachten, die der wissenschaftliche Dienst gemacht hatte.
Der wissenschaftliche Dienst macht jedes Jahr vom Bundestag ein paar tausend
Gutachten und die waren alle erst mal nicht für die Öffentlichkeit bestimmt
und dann hat aber ein Journalist das durchgeklagt bis vor das Bundesverwaltungsgericht,
dass unter anderem die Gutenberg-Gutachten herausgegeben werden mussten und
die UFO-Gutachten auch.
UFO-Gutachten. Gibt es auch, ja. Eine sächsische CDU-Abgeordnete hat das in Auftrag gegeben.
Und damit, ja, Bundesverwaltungsgericht hat gesagt, Gutachten müssen auf einzelne
Anfrage herausgegeben werden.
Dann sind wir zum Bundestag gegangen und haben gesagt, okay,
wenn die E auf einzelne Anfrage herausgegeben werden muss.
Gebt sie doch alle raus. Und dann haben die gesagt, nee, danke.
Und dann haben wir uns eine Liste besorgt von all diesen Gutachten.
Haben die dann durchsuchbar gemacht. Und dann konnte man sie einzeln anklicken.
Wenn man sie angeklickt hat, hat es eine Anfrage danach rausgesendet am Bundestag.
Und das haben dann innerhalb von zwei Wochen, ich glaube, 3000 Leute gemacht.
Und dann hat es noch eine Woche gedauert. Und Lammert damals hat gesagt,
okay, veröffentlichen wir alles.
Genau, und das ist so das Grundbezimmer.
Jetzt habt ihr euch ja ein neues Opfer gesucht und diese Open Shufa-Geschichte gestartet.
Was war denn da jetzt so der Anlass, Motivation und auch diese neue Kooperation?
Genau, das ist eine Kooperation von der Open Knowledge Foundation mit Algorithm Watch.
Und uns geht es darum, die Shufa zu knacken. Also in den Schufa-Algorithmus
die Art, wie der Schufa-Score oder man muss sagen die Schufa-Scores eigentlich
so generiert werden, herauszufinden.
Und das Mittel, das wir nutzen, ist Selbstauskunftsanfragen nach dem Datenschutzgesetz,
jetzt DSGVO, wo einzelne Leute ihre Daten kriegen können von der Schufa.
Und die Idee ist, dass so viele Leute wie möglich dann die Daten,
die sie bekommen, pseudonymisiert an uns spenden.
Und wenn wir so viele Daten wie möglich haben, also das sind dann Tabellen mit
verschiedenen Scores plus verschiedene Daten, die wir noch dazu einsammeln,
ist jemand, Mann oder Frau,
gelistet in der Schufa-Datenbank, wie viele Kredite hat man oder so,
dann kann man das idealerweise mit verschiedenen statistischen Verfahren so
zurückleiten, dass man sehen kann, okay, diese Faktoren haben offensichtlich
einen Einfluss auf den Schufa-Score und diese nicht.
Das heißt so ein bisschen die Frage, diskriminiert die Schufa mit ihrem Algorithmus oder nicht?
Würdest du davon ausgehen, dass du den gesamten Algorithmus rauskriegst?
Oder würdest du einfach nur sagen, okay, wir schauen im Ergebnis,
ob der Algorithmus am Ende Menschengruppen ungleich behandelt?
Ich glaube, wir kommen in die Nähe. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir die exakte Formel haben.
Wobei uns schon gesagt wurde wahrscheinlich ist die Schufa-Formel jetzt nicht
wahnsinnig komplex aber ich glaube wir können sicherlich so einige Sachen ausschließen
wir können einige Sachen beobachten,
auf jeden Fall highlighten. Und dann ist die große Frage, was damit passiert eigentlich.
Und die Schufa, die ist bisher sehr, sehr feindlich gegenüber dieser Kampagne gewesen.
Ach was, wirklich? Mann, ey.
Also das fand ich wirklich bemerkenswert, das hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass man so eine Medienstrategie heutzutage noch hat.
Die Reaktionen von der Schufa, nachdem wir online gegangen sind,
ein paar Stunden später hatten die eine,
das waren sieben DIN-A4-Seiten auf schufa.de, wo sie die die Kampagne irreführend
als Gefahr für die Sicherheit und den Datenschutz in Deutschland genannt haben.
Und das war verlinkt auf der Startseite von der Schufa für eine ganze Woche lang.
Das heißt, wenn man auf schufa.de gesehen hat, gegangen ist,
hat man erst mal Open Schufa gesehen. Beste Werbung, die man sich vorstellen kann.
Tatsächlich, einige Leute haben sich an uns gewendet und meinten,
eigentlich wollte ich nicht mitmachen. Jetzt haben wir das von der Schufa gelesen.
Wir machen trotzdem. Also jetzt machen wir mit.
Also das ist zum einen bemerkenswert, die sträuben sich gegen alles und zum
anderen bemerkenswert ist, wie die zuständigen Datenschutzbehörden darauf reagieren,
denn der hessische Datenschutzbeauftragte ist zuständig für die Prüfung und
wie die Prüfung abläuft ist,
die Schufa gibt einen gutachtenden Auftrag und bezahlt es, gibt es dann dem
Datenschutzbeauftragten und der prüft das.
Bezahlte ihn auch noch mal.
Der Datenschutzbeauftragte prüft nicht die Schufa, sondern er prüft nur das
Gutachten, was die Schufa selber bezahlt hat?
Korrekt.
Wenn das der TÜV auch so machen würde.
Ich schreibe da mal ein Gutachten vor mir.
Und dann hat die FAZ ein Stück drüber gemacht und hat den zuständigen Mitarbeiter
bei der Behörde interviewt und der meinte, ich verstehe gar nicht,
was das mit der Kampagne soll, sinngemäß.
Ich habe doch das gesehen und es war okay.
Und das ist so dieses Grundverständnis, gegen das wir halt auch angehen wollen,
das geht dann über Datenschutz hinaus, es geht halt um öffentliche Kontrolle
und es geht um öffentliche Nachvollziehbarkeit und es reicht halt nicht,
dass eine Behörde das gesehen hat, sondern wenn es so enorme gesellschaftliche Auswirkungen hat,
dann muss halt auch die Gesellschaft selbst überprüfen können und dann muss
es da mehr Transparenzmöglichkeiten und letztlich auch mehr Kontrollmöglichkeiten geben.
Aber da kommt ja dann immer gleich das Argument von der Schufa,
naja, wenn wir jetzt unsere Algorithmen offenlegen, dann werden wir ja gecheatet.
Das ist ein Problem, das die Schufa hat, nicht wir.
Naja.
Schufa, das hat so ein bisschen, ja, um es mal vielleicht ein bisschen umzudrehen,
so ein bisschen wie mit der GEMA, da kannst du immer draufhauen und hast immer einen, der klatscht.
Das waren jetzt mehr.
Ja.
Sogar egal, wie du draufhaust, da findest du immer einen, der klatscht.
Und man kann ja jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass jetzt für niemanden kein vertretbarer
Nutzen ist, der auch irgendwie im Sinne aller, weißt du, also sie jetzt immer
nur so als die bösen Dämonen hinzustellen,
ist auch Quatsch, weil sie ja schon ein Rädchen im Wirtschaftssystem sind,
wo man es bis drüber diskutieren kann, ob das sozusagen, also worauf ich hinaus
will, ist, das ist schon, das hat ja auch eine gewisse,
Legitimität sozusagen von der Stelle und lässt sich das sozusagen überhaupt so öffentlich machen?
Also denkst du, dass man quasi algorithmisch oder wie auch immer man das dann
aufbaut, sich dieselbe Dienstleistung, sozusagen der positive Aspekt davon auch
sicher lässt und gleichzeitig auch diese öffentliche Kontrolle.
Ja, also ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt unbedingt die Formel veröffentlicht werden muss.
Die Weltformel.
Die Weltformel der Schufa. Aber ich glaube, wir müssen wissen,
welche Aspekte da einfließen und welche nicht.
Wir müssen wissen, ob es einen Unterschied macht, ob ich fünfmal umgezogen bin oder zehnmal.
Es könnte sein, dass bestimmte Lebensstile letztlich damit dann abgestraft werden.
Was vielleicht mathematisch oder ökonomisch sinnvoll wäre, für die Schufa da
reinzutun, aber halt gesellschaftlich und mit den Auswirkungen, die das hätte, nicht.
Und das müssen wir überprüfen können. Und wenn es dann so cheatbar wäre,
dass man ein paar Mal mehr umzieht und dadurch einen besseren Score hat,
dann wäre das tatsächlich ein Problem der Schufa und nicht von uns.
Das heißt, wenn die Schufa da sagt, ist alles gar nicht so schlimm und es ist
wissenschaftlich überprüft,
Es ist wissenschaftlich überprüft, das sagen sie ja, dann ist ja ganz klar,
wissenschaftliche Überprüfbarkeit bedeutet halt, dass alle Leute sich das anschauen
können und überprüfen können.
Wissenschaftlich ist es halt nicht, wenn zwei Leute das gesehen haben.
Du hast ja gesagt, Algorithm Watch macht das Projekt mit.
Da kommt natürlich noch eine ganz andere Komponente da rein,
nämlich nicht nur, dass es jetzt die Schufa betrifft, sondern die ist einfach
nur das prominenteste Beispiel eines völlig nicht dokumentierten,
nicht nachvollziehbaren, nicht geprüften Entscheidungsalgorithmus,
den wir in unserer Welt schon hinnehmen.
Das wird doch sicherlich auch bei der Auswahl eine Rolle gespielt haben,
weil wir wahrscheinlich in eine Zukunft blicken, wo wir uns da mehr dran gewöhnen.
Wenn wir das schon bei der Schufa hinnehmen, dann bin ich gespannt,
wo wir das noch überall hinnehmen würden in Zukunft, ohne da einfach mal zu
sagen, Moment, da werden irgendwie offenbar automatisiert Entscheidungen getroffen.
Wie kommen die denn zustande?
Genau, und das Beispiel, was dann immer genannt wird, ist halt das Social Scoring in China.
Und schaut mal, wie weit die sind. Wenn du da einen schlechten Score hast,
dann darfst du nicht mehr fliegen und wenn du dann,
weiß ich nicht, das sind so wahnsinnig viele Beispiele, im Straßenverkehr einen
Fehler machst, dann hast du nachher bei irgendwelchen Einkäufen ein Problem
und da sieht man, glaube ich, ganz gut, wohin das geht und das ist aber auch nicht nur China.
Also ähnliche Programme gibt es ja an vielen Orten und auch die Schufe hatte
schon mal ein Programm, wo sie Social Media Auswertung gemacht hat.
Das heißt, das ist alles da.
Die Frage ist halt, ob da die Gesellschaft genug drauf schaut oder nicht.
Und wo denkst du, geht das jetzt so hin?
Also mit dem Projekt einerseits und hast du schon was anderes in der Mache?
Und kannst du vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen was dazu sagen,
wie du so die Rolle als Programmierer, Algorithmiker und in dieser Aktivistenrolle
siehst und ob du da auch Empfehlungen aussprechen kannst?
Das waren jetzt drei Fragen, ne?
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich bin schon spät.
Wir müssen jetzt drei auf einmal machen, ist spät.
Und das, wo wir noch vier Minuten haben.
Ja, ja und schwierig.
Das waren nochmal die drei Fragen.
Danke. Das ist so, das ist so, weil mit der Zukunft ist ja auch alles schwierig.
Also so Programmieren und Aktivismus, da ist ja irgendwie was Neues entstanden.
Nicht nur durch Frag den Staat, auch viele andere Systeme, auch was hier Thomas
Lohninger mit seiner Crew da auf EU-Ebene mit Netzneutralität gemacht hat.
So dieses automatisierte Raussuchen von Abgeordneten und ruft die mal an etc.
Ist ja im Prinzip auch Werkzeuge schaffen, um Politik zu organisieren.
Genau und besonders spannend finde ich das immer dann, wenn tatsächlich auch
Rechtsgrundlagen genutzt werden, mit denen man was durchsetzen kann.
Und das ist das, was wir dann vor allem machen.
Also natürlich kann man auch Petitionen machen und dann unterschreibt man.
Und im Idealfall generiert man dadurch eine Öffentlichkeit, also es kann ja
wunderbar funktionieren, aber in den meisten Fällen wird es wahrscheinlich halt
irgendein Klick gewesen sein.
Wenn man eine IFG-Anfrage nutzt, wenn man eine Datenschutz-Grundverordnung nutzt,
dann hat man ein Mittel, das dann Behörden oder Unternehmen befolgen müssen.
Und dann, glaube ich, wird es spannend, wenn man tatsächlich nicht nur als Einzelner,
sondern in einer Gruppe und massenhaft Rechte durchsetzen kann.
Und das wird jetzt halt möglich und das finde ich spannend. Und mit der DSGVO
wird es europaweit möglich.
Und das wird dann auch noch mal besonders spannend, wenn halt so ein Open Shufa-Projekt
nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern vielleicht europaweit dann mal losgelassen wird.
Und darauf hoffe ich, dass das mehr passiert.
Ihr hattet in der letzten Folge den BND-Generator von Reporter ohne Grenzen.
Das war auch noch mal sowas.
2000 Leute schicken eine Mail
ab und sagen, hier gibt es dieses Urteil und jetzt nehmt mich da raus.
Und das funktioniert sehr schnell. Ich glaube, das funktioniert.
Da, in die Richtung, sollte noch mehr passieren. Und da setze ich so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung bei.
Also die drei Programmierer, die es in Deutschland noch gibt,
die jetzt nicht schon von der Straße geholt wurden bei der großen Nachfrage, können sich bei.
Der Open Knowledge Foundation bewerben, auf 1,3 stellen.
Man kann euch spenden, Daten spenden und Geld spenden.
Ich habe gerade, als du auf die Bühne gekommen bist, habe ich gesehen,
ich habe meine Schufa-Auskunft hinten im Rucksack liegen lassen.
Die wollte ich dir eigentlich hier noch geben, mal recht danach.
Aber du willst sie wahrscheinlich eh lieber digital haben.
Sonst muss ich sie einscannen.
Ich habe die schon gescannt und nochmal ausgedruckt.
Ich gucke mal, wenn die.
Genau.
Ja, wir haben das Portal zur Datenspende jetzt online, also openschufa.de.
Da kann man Schufa-Auskunft, die man hat, direkt aus dem Handy oder mit einem
Scan hochladen, schwärzen, wenn man will.
Und das alles sehr einfach machen.
Frag den Staat, nimmt sehr gerne Spenden, damit wir bald 1,4 Stellen haben.
Oder 5.
Oder 5, genau. Ist das der Schlusssatz?
Weiß ich nicht.
Haben wir noch Zeit?
Eine Minute hast du noch.
Okay, es laufen gerade die...
Wir haben noch eine Minute.
Es laufen gerade die IFG-Meisterschaften.
Da bin ich total dabei. Die Informationsfreiheitsmeisterschaften hat FragDenStaat gegründet.
Das Prinzip ist, passend zum World Cup, 16 Teams, 16 Ministerien.
Allen haben wir die gleiche Auskunftsanfrage geschickt und die treten in Duellen gegeneinander an.
Kann man bei Kommenwetten?
Ich habe mir das noch ein bisschen angeguckt. Als gemeinnützige Organisation
mit Wetten ist es ein bisschen schwierig.
Schade.
Aber wer halt zuerst vollständig antwortet, kommt in die nächste Runde und wir
sind jetzt schon im Viertelfinale.
Und was ich so spannend finde an dem Ganzen ist, das Innenministerium macht
mit und die sind voll dabei.
Also ich kriege von denen in der Regel immer erst nach einem Monat oder später
eine Antwort und immer wollen die Geld von mir haben.
Und im Viertelfinale habe ich denen die Anfrage geschickt und nach einem Tag
hatte ich das kostenlos.
Und dann haben wir das getweetet. hier, BMI ist schon im Halbfinale, Horst Seehofer, wow.
Und dann der Twitter-Account von BMI hat dann so ein GIF geantwortet, so.
Und,
vielleicht ist das die Lösung. Also man denkt immer, Gamification,
um irgendwie Leute für Politik zu interessieren.
Ich glaube, wir müssen die Politik gamifizieren.
Man muss die Politik für die Leute interessieren.
GIFification, ja. Oh Mann.
Ich glaube, da haben wir jetzt wirklich einen Sendungstitel.
Mit Gamification, die Politik für die Leute interessiert.
Das ist doch schön. Arne, vielen Dank.
Sehr gerne.
Ich würde jetzt danken.
Das ist reiner vorab.
Ich sage jetzt schon, dass ich wahrscheinlich eine oder zwei Personen auf dieser Liste vergesse.
Das ist immer das Problem. Ja, ich weiß es dem, aber man kann ja trotzdem mal Danke sagen.
Das ist okay.
Wir danken für das Design Sven Sedivi. Ihr könnt dann immer auch applaudieren
für die Leute, dann freuen wir uns mehr.
Wir können mal am Schluss applaudieren, sonst dauert es nicht mehr.
Wir müssen wirklich reisen.
Wir danken dem Wort der Peter, Mo, Björn und Zichi da oben.
Wir danken Papillon und Tomate für allgemeinen Support in allen Lebenslagen.
Wir danken Tobi, Thomas und Christa für den Shirtverkauf.
Sebas, Local Horse und Hausy für den Einlass.
Roland fürs Livezeichnen.
Henning, Letty und Dennis für das Jeopardy.
Den Jeopardy-Spielern und Spielerinnen.
Die habe ich hier nicht draufgestellt, ich kenne es jetzt so schnell nicht hin.
Und den LNP-Co-Moderatorin André Meister, der auch da ist, der nimmt auch immer Bier entgegen.
Und Thomas Lohninger, der heute leider nicht bei uns sein konnte.
Und ja, das müsst ihr mit ihm klären. Und der Support habe ich Niki vergessen. Vielen Dank.
Und natürlich Martina Renner, Géraldine de Bastion und Arne Semsroth.
Und natürlich nicht zu vergessen,
die LNP Einhorn-Standarte, die uns immer hilft und noch viel wichtiger,
euch allen, die uns hört und auch besucht, das finden wir ganz toll und ich
hoffe, ihr bleibt uns auch weiter
treu und ich glaube, wir werden auch weiterhin eine Menge Spaß haben.
Vielen Dank fürs Kommen, super, dass ihr da wart. Das war's.
Danke sehr.